- How do we podcast again?
- It feels so weird doing
this somewhere else.
- Yeah, I know.
- I'm just, I don't feel comfortable.
(gentle music)
- Hey, guys, welcome
to another Trash Taste
episode.
(Connor burps)
- Oh, sorry. Can you do that?
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Startin' things off good, I see.
- Sorry, sorry, I had to burp.
- If you couldn't tell, we're
in a different location.
In fact, we're on the road right now.
We're in the beautiful city of London.
- I thought you were gonna say
the beautiful city of England. (laughing)
- Yeah, the beautiful city
of the United Kingdom.
- England is my city.
(Garnt laughing)
And no, I'm not from Compton. (chuckles)
- Hopefully, it looks good.
So, we brought our cameras.
We are using different mics.
So hopefully, it won't be too different
of a Trash Taste experience.
And it should be like this for
like two or three episodes.
So if you like the old setup,
or you like a different setup,
we'll mix it up.
We'll mix it up, so don't worry.
- We're gonna have a few weeks here.
We're gonna film a few episodes here.
Then we're gonna change places again.
'Cause we are on the road right now.
- Exactly.
- This is a very like
gorilla kind of setup.
We kind of brought
all of our equipment from-
(Joey laughs)
- It is Janken's behind fault
behind this camera there.
(Garnt laughs)
- Oh my God, I walked in
this room, and I'm like,
"This is like making me feel nostalgic."
- Yeah, it's like the old studio.
There's like the trip hazards are back.
Like there's wires everywhere.
But hopefully, we're making it work.
- Yeah.
But hey, welcome back.
This is, I guess, the proper
like start to season three
of Trash Taste now.
- Oh yeah, season three.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And by the time we were recording this,
we had just finished MCM London.
- Yeah, which I think by
the time of releasing,
won't be too far after we went there,
about two weeks, I think.
- Yeah.
- Is it? Is that how-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
round about two weeks.
- Oh, I didn't know that.
Oh my God.
- Yeah, it would be two.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I'm like, "Where the fuck are we
in my Trash Taste time?"
(Garnt laughing)
- I have no idea. I have no idea.
But yeah, it was my first MCM London.
Actually, this is only
my second time in London,
just in general.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So, MCM is a, I dunno
what it stands for, but-
- It's Comic Con, basically.
- It's Comic Con. It's London Comic Con.
And it's like
the biggest UK convention.
- Massive Comic Con, mate.
(all laugh)
- Massive Comic, mate.
(Garnt laughing)
Massive Comic meetup.
- It's like an A1.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Everyone has A1 comics.
No, but I mean, yeah, it's
good to be back there.
We haven't gone in like three years.
- I mean, this is my first
convention since 2019 AX.
- I think it is for all of us.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, me too.
- So that was the last
convention we all went to.
And I believe the last Comic Con,
or the last MCM I went to,
was probably 2018, I think.
No, maybe even 2017
because I went to MomoCon
like one of the few years,
and it was the same weekend as MCM.
So it's been a very, very long time
since I've been to MCM.
- Right.
- Right, right, right.
- Well, regardless, it was
a very different experience
this time.
- Yeah, not only
it was our first con in three years,
but it was also our first
con as "Trash Taste,"
so we had no idea what to expect,
and (laughs) a lot of shit happened,
that's for sure.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, it kind of put
things into perspective.
Just one, like how long it's been
since Trash Taste has started.
And two, how long it's been
since the world has moved on
since Trash Taste has started.
Because I remember like, this is,
not anything to do with MCM,
but I remember like we met Kevin.
I met Kevin and his partner.
- Kevin Penkin, by the way. (chuckles)
- Yeah, Kevin Penkin, sorry.
So I should have (laughs)
- This is just Kevin, you know.
- It's just Kevin.
You know Kevin.
- Our mate, Kevin.
- You know the Kevin.
There's only one Kevin
in the world.
- Garnt's the worst at this.
Garnt just throws names out
that mean nothing to people.
(Garnt laughing)
- So we met our friend, Bob.
- Yeah, you know Bob.
- It's like,
Garnt either don't say anyone's
name or just fully explain.
(all laughing)
- Sorry, you met Kevin Penkin
who has flown over here
to the UK as well.
And I remember the first thing
his partner says to me is,
"Oh, congratulations on
everything, by the way."
And I'm like, "Well, what
are you talking about?"
And she's just like, "You
guys have been killing it.
And I'm just like so proud of you guys."
And I'm like,
- Aw.
- "Wait, I haven't met you
since before Trash Taste started.
That's so fuckin' surreal to me, right?
'Cause I feel like the
last time I met Kevin
was just like a year or two ago.
And I'm just like, "Wait,
the last time I met Kevin,
Trash Taste didn't exist."
- No.
- It was nothing.
- It feels like-
we started it two months ago,
but in reality, it's been
too whole freakin' years.
And it's just like...
And that two years though,
it's just gone like that.
- Yeah, and now like meeting people,
for like meeting friends
who I count as like really,
really close friends,
and them congratulating me
for starting Trash Taste
is like so fuckin' weird.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
You know, I'm like,
"Startin' to congrats
on starting Trash Taste,
what are we, like episode
five or something? (laughing)
- Yeah, right. (chuckles)
"Hey, you guys got a long
way to go to go still."
(Garnt laughing)
Meanwhile, we had just released
100 episodes this year.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- It makes you realized how
isolated you are in Japan.
'Cause like, you know,
- Yeah, definitely.
- we don't get to speak much
English outside of our crew.
So it's so like, you
know, it's like 10 of us,
and then, no one else.
- Yeah.
- But then obviously here
it's like, "Oh, your friends,
or there's, "Oh, their
friend knows Trash Taste,
but it's like our friends don't know,
outside of our group here,
no one knows Trash Taste
'cause they don't fuckin'
watch English podcasts.
- Yeah.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Suffering with success,
is that what we're titling this episode?
- Probably, yeah.
- Yeah, probably.
- Suffering from success.
- Fuckin' DJ comics.
- [Garnt] Oh God.
- Suffering from DJ comics.
- Yeah, but it was a first MCM for me.
I'd only heard of MCM
from these guys mostly.
And you know, I was like,
"Okay, it's like, what, the
biggest con in the UK, probably?
- Yeah.
- Maybe-
- Definitely.
- Probably by far.
- No, it's definitely the biggest.
It's definitely the biggest.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Not the biggest con-
- MCM London.
- in Europe, though, right?
- No, no.
- No, that's Japan Con,
I believe.
I'm gonna guess.
- Oh, AnimeJapan.
- No, isn't it-
- No, it's Games Con,
isn't it, in Germany?
- Oh, I was talking
about anime conventions.
- Let's see whose
bullshit is the best here.
- I think it might be...
I heard there's an anime-
- [Sound bite] Your fingerprint.
(Connor laughing)
I know there's a Japan expo
in Paris that's gigantic.
- AnimeJapan.
- AnimeJapan,
something like that.
- I thought it was Japan Expo.
- Something with like-
- Is it?
Oh, I don't know.
- It's got the fuckin' rotary
of like Anime Expo/Japan.
It's like mix and match, bro.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
It's one of them. I don't
know which one it is.
- Are we all talking
about the same convention?
- We're all talking-
- I don't fuckin' know.
- about the same convention
because we don't remember
what it's for. (chuckles)
(Joey laughing)
- Japan Expo, yeah.
I think now that you said
Japan Expo, it makes sense.
- It's huge, but I don't
know anyone who's gone to it.
But I mean, that's 'cause
British people, I don't know,
we're like, "France? Oh, God."
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
And then there's Games Con in Germany,
which is also huge.
- I've been to Games Con.
Games Con is massive.
Like I remember I went to
Games Con, and like I was like,
"Yeah, man, I kinda..."
This is when the Switch
was about to come out.
- Right.
- And I remember that Nintendo had a booth
to play Super Mario Odyssey
for like 10 minutes.
And the line was like eight hours.
(Garnt laughing)
And it was ridiculous.
There was a Japanese woman
just standing outside
with like a thing that said,
"Oh, the wait time is like
600 minutes," or something.
- Oh, my God.
- I was like, "What?"
And people were like
joining in this queue.
I'm like, "You know, the thing
closes before this is done.
What do you want?
(Garnt laughing)
What is this math?
But like, Games Con is like so big
that also I feel like you
can't really do anything.
Like it gets to a point
where it's almost, you know,
it's like this has reached a capacity
where I can no longer do anything.
I think I played like...
The only games you could actually get on
in a reasonable amount of time
were like the games that were destined
to fuckin' fail the moment they came out.
The games that nobody gave a fuck about.
- Is it kinda like E3 in a sense?
- Yeah, it's E3, but for Europe.
But it's open to the public, I think,
all days by one.
And it was just like, it was insane.
I don't really wanna go back.
I think if I were to go back,
it would be under like a
press pass or something
where you can just be like,
"See, you losers, I'm going in line.
I'm gonna go to the front."
'Cause it's just like-
- Just cut the entire line, yeah.
- I'm hype for like...
I was hype for Super Mario Odyssey,
but I'm not waiting over an hour hype,
like an hour was putting
my personal limit.
- I don't think I'm like
anything is worth me
waiting an hour in terms
of like games for me.
I can't think of a single
game where I'm just like,
"Yo, okay, two-hour line,
two-hour wait time for like a
five-minute demo or something?
Yo, let's go! Let's go!"
- I think the longest I ever waited
was like an hour and a half,
hour and 40, at TGS to play Persona 5.
- Right. Was it worth it?
- An hour and 40.
- I mean, yeah, but you
know how long that game is,
So five minutes is not a lot of time.
So, you know, like-
- Yeah, exactly. (laughing)
- You can't do anything.
- you can't get into it.
You can't sink your teeth
into it, what's the point.
You know what I mean?
- Not at all, not at all.
- Like you're just teasing.
- And it's like, I knew I
was gonna buy it anyway.
So I was just like, at the
end of the hour and 40,
I got to the front of the line,
and I was like, "Wow, that was
(motorcycle revving)
a bike?
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Definitely not as quite as our studio.
- Yeah.
Like I was waiting for
like an hour and 30,
an hour and 40 minutes,
and then I got to the front
of line, and I was just like,
"Wow, I don't know if this
was even worth it or not."
(Joey laughing)
- Oh bro,
you know what I actually, a
play game I played at Games Con
and there was like no line for?
This is before Cuphead came out,
and I was like so fuckin'
hyped to play Cuphead,
and it was only like a 10-minute wait.
- [Joey] Oh, really?
- Oh, that's awesome.
- And I played Cuphead,
and I was like, "Fuck
ya, this game is awesome.
I can't wait to buy it."
- Hell ya.
- And it was good. It was good.
- But yeah, so we went to MCM.
We were there for three days.
Well, I mean, Connor and I
were there for three days.
Connor and I went there
on a Saturday.
- I was there for
(clears throat) one day just
because I had some things to do
in and out here and there,
so I only wanted to commit to one day.
But yeah, how was your first
UK con experience, Joey?
- I mean, we'll get into details later,
but it was lot of ups and a
lot of downs, that's for sure.
It was very much a roller coaster.
I mean like I expected British
fans to be super chill,
and they were for the most part,
but of course, you know, at
the same time, it's like,
this is our first con
as Trash Taste, right?
- Trash Taste, yeah, yeah.
- So it's like, I knew that
my fans, The Anime Man fans,
like British fans, would be
like chill as they usually are.
- Are you blaming Trash Taste for this?
(Garnt laughing)
What the fuck?
- I mean like, could you say
that it was like 100% chill?
- I mean, I think-
- It was, for the most part,
100% chill.
- It was like,
okay, so here's the thing,
it was like 99.9% chill.
- Yeah.
- But then, there were like
those one or two people
that obviously really, really stood out,
and some of them even made waves.
You might have even seen some clips online
about some of the people
we've had to deal with
over the weekend.
- Yeah.
- Because it just like,
the intensity was just like
way more intense than anything
that I've ever experienced
in my life before.
- I'm like the same, yeah.
- Me and Joey, we walked around on...
So it was a three-day con,
Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
And they have this odd ticket system
that I've never seen any other con,
where like every single day
they have a priority ticket,
which means you can come in from nine.
And then a general ticket,
which means you can come
in from, I think, 11 or 12,
something like that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I was really
confused about that system.
- I didn't quite get
it. It's just cheaper.
I don't really understand it.
But we walked around on
like Friday at 10:00 AM
before everyone got in.
And like, we could walk
around, it's pretty chill.
We got stopped a lot.
- We got stopped.
Yeah, we got stopped every now and then.
- But like, we could
still walk, like we went
to get around.
- But like, you went Friday,
10:00 AM, which is literally
the deadest time-
- the deadest time, yeah.
- of the entire week.
- Yeah. (chuckling)
You're not gonna get a deader time
than that time.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- So at least I got to
actually like walk around
even for a little bit to actually
see what the con was like
and all the other places,
'cause it's freaking massive, isn't it?
- Yeah.
- It's really big.
It's just like 20 warehouses
attached to each other.
- Yeah, exactly.
- But, yeah, that was cool.
But then, once the
actual general admission
started to come in around like 11, 12 ish,
it got very heated very quickly.
It got very packed.
- So, what was your guys' expectation
going into this convention?
- I was expecting like,
"Okay, obviously more people
are gonna know us now,
not just for individual
stuff, but for Trash Taste,
If anything, there's
probably gonna be more people
who know us for Trash Taste,
but I wasn't expecting it
to be like 10 times as much.
- No, I mean, I had some expectations,
obviously I expected to be more recognized
and everything like that, now
that I've shown my face more,
got an extra channel now
where you just talk shit
with the boys, you know?
- Yeah.
- But this was definitely like
an eye-opening weekend for me
because we've speculated before
about what an anime convention
is going to be like now
since Trash Taste has started.
And I think this weekend
has definitely cemented
that anime conventions will
never be the same again for us.
And it's like, it was like
a bittersweet realization
because I remember we were all...
It was a Saturday when we
all realized this, I think.
And it was right after our panel.
So we had our first Trash
Taste panel ever, ever!
And for the most part,
I thought it was good,
but then there was some
really, really standout things
that it's hard to forget
about our first Trash Taste experience.
- So if you've been living under a rock,
there's probably about
30 different perspectives
of some dude running up onto the stage
(Garnt laughing)
and 30 different perspectives of me
shitting my pants on stage.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, I mean, we weren't really like...
We didn't really prepare
anything. That's kind of on us.
Like we could have prepared
something, we didn't.
Just like, we were gonna do a Q&A.
We were just, "We'll just do-"
- Yeah, just keep it simple,
like how we've always done.
- Yeah, 'cause we we've always done panels
where it's just, "Okay, Q&A, easy."
We don't need to think too much about it,
people are normally chill.
It's a Q&A, you know what I mean?
It's like, "How rout up can
fans get most of the times?"
- But I mean, the thing is with the Q&A,
it's completely made
by how good are the questions people ask.
And I think it's just like
roll of the dice sometimes
that some people just ask questions
that were either just like
cringy or would ask questions
that didn't really actually
make us talk about anything.
It was just kinda like,
"What's your favorite anime?"
And it's like, "All right,
is this okay or maybe not?"
- It was kind like,
there was also like a lot of
like very loaded questions
where it's like, everyone
knew the answer to it
before it was asked.
And it's like, "Why
would you ask a question
that everyone already
knows the answer to?"
- I mean, I'd say, for the most
part, we had good questions.
- There was some good ones?
- Yeah, yeah.
I think like, okay,
I'm gonna say this now.
I'm gonna say this now, right?
If you ask Connor about his
relationship status, just stop.
- You'll cringe, bro.
- It is cringe.
I'm gonna call out 'cause like
when we see it on comments,
and I've read it, it's like...
Connor's commented on it in the past.
Like now, as a mate seeing
it in real life on stage,
I'm just like, "Come on, guys."
- It's cringe, stop it.
- Come on, please don't,
please don't.
- Stop.
- Thanks, boys.
Thanks, boys. Thanks, boys.
- I'm sorry.
It's just like-
- Don't hold me back!
(Connor and Joey laugh)
- I got this! I got you! (chuckles)
- It's just a question that
people always wanna know.
'cause they're fuckin'-
- Like I understand
the curiosity.
- Yeah, people wanna know, and I get it.
My thing is like, alright,
if one person asks,
I'll make some joke and tell you,
"Yeah, funny, haha, I'm dating Chris."
And then, it was just like,
okay, then someone else
just asked again afterwards.
And then, it's like, "All
right, he just asked that like,
and you didn't get an answer.
You're not gonna get a fuckin'...
I'm not gonna tell you anything."
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
Like, "Don't ask me this shit!"
- Yeah, it's like, "Oh, we
didn't get a full answer.
What if I ask again?"
(Garnt and Joey chuckle)
- It's like, whether I did or didn't,
or I'm married with four kids,
I'll talk about it if
I wanna talk about it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's frustrating.
- If someone wants to
keep something private,
then let them keep their privacy.
- [Garnt And Connor] Yeah.
- That's not me confirming
or denying anything,
so shut the fuck up for
actually speculating.
(Garnt laughing)
- They're gonna be like, "Psychoanalyze,
breakdown word for word."
- Enhance.
You know, 'cause it's
parasocial andy's, dude.
I don't know how
(chuckling) to say it, dude.
It's just what it is.
You know, it sucks, but I
know it's like a part of,
how it is.
- I guess it was just like,
we've seen the comments and everything,
and I'm sure you get it on
your Twitch chat all the time.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- Hearing it in person, like as a mate,
I'm just like, I felt my bro, man.
I felt my bro.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I would feel uncomfortable
if like I was asked that
that involves me and Syndey.
- It's happened
so many times now where it's kind of like,
"All right, I just have the
routine of dealing with it,
of like, "Haha, dating Chris."
- But that's
the one thing I like.
That's another one that
I've kind of figured out,
like going to this
convention, doing the panel,
is that like it...
Because we've talked about
parasocial relationships
so many freakin' times on
the show, and it's like,
you'd think that after the amount of times
we've talked about it,
people start to be like,
"Okay, yeah I get the
boys' perspectives on it."
- But there's also the fact
where if you talk about
parasocial relationships,
it makes it seem like,
"Okay, the person listening is
in a parasocial relationship
'cause they're listening, they're hearing.
But then it's like,
okay, but it doesn't
always like translate well.
- Yeah.
- But also I understand
how like on the day,
sometimes people get in weird
moods and some things happen.
- Well, I get it. You're
like, "Yeah, yeah."
- I will say that it was, like I said, 99,
like I met like a lot of people there.
And the people I can
respect was just like,
"Look, I know 'cause you've
talked about it plenty of times.
I know you more than you know me.
I just wanna say, I get that,
and I still love your stuff.
I still respect everything you've done."
And that was like just a genuine,
okay I met like a few people
at the bar, at the hotel,
who I just had just had a
genuine conversation with
from like that starting
point, where, you know,
"We acknowledge this,
but I still wanna get to know this person
because we're in a environment
where I can get to have
a more chilled conversation about it."
But then, you do just get
these one or two maybe fans
who just don't watch Trash
Taste as often as other people.
'Cause especially like
reading the subreddit
and reading how much people
have called this out,
I'm just like,
"That's fuckin' great."
(clapping hands)
Unfortunately, not everyone of our viewers
is on the subreddit, for example.
Not every viewer watches every episode.
So you will get that casual viewer
who just doesn't know more,
like doesn't know about the boundaries
as much as like other viewers, I think.
- I dunno.
I mean, to me it was like,
this is just all a learning experience.
Like this is no way made me
not wanna go to cons or anything.
- [Garnt and Joey] No, no, no.
- Like we've said this a
million times, but yeah,
everyone was super fuckin' nice.
The signings were great.
Everyone was really respectful,
except you got shot by a Nerf
gun by someone. (laughing)
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that wasn't cool.
I wasn't there to see, but-
- So, it was 'cause it's like open, right?
- Yeah, it was open.
- So, we had like a table,
and there was three of us.
I was in the middle, Joey was on the end,
and then there's Garnt on this end.
And this end is completely open,
so anyone could have walked up
and thrown anything at Garnt,
which is just an oversight.
They should have had someone
there who is stopping this.
- I think it was like...
It's a learning experience.
It's not just for us, but
for the convention itself,
for the convention as well.
So like, I remember the
conversation where we talked about,
we don't know if we need security
for future conventions yet.
This taught us that we definitely do need-
- [Joey] Yeah, we
definitely do. (laughing)
We definitely do need security.
Like that was like a very
much a big eye opener for us.
- I mean, obviously we
had the incident happened
where someone came on the
stage, who apparently...
Okay, so this is the whole fuckin' thing.
You said it was a learning
experience with the convention.
I feel like, I don't know,
they should know that
it would've been better.
And to be fair, they stepped it up,
but I feel like it should
have been there anyway.
We practically had no security really
for like the first two days.
- Yeah, I think they definitely
should have had security
for the panel.
But I talked to some people
afterwards, who working there,
and they said, "This has
never happened before.
This has never even
become close to happening.
There was never like a precedence
of this like ever happening at MCM."
So it was also, it wasn't oversight,
but also, like a lot of
people just didn't expect it
'cause it just never happened before.
- I mean, yeah, I agree, and
I don't wanna go too hard,
'cause obviously, like we
wanna go to cons again,
but like it blows my mind
that you would have a main stage event
and not have like at least
one scary dude in the front,
'cause like it was anyone
could have come up,
everyone could have come up. (chuckles)
- And it's still like MCM
haven't had insanely large guests
in the past.
So I'm thinking like, "What do they do-"
- Well, they had like Tom Hiddleston.
- Yeah, and it's like
there's no way Tom Hiddleston
could do a panel on stage,
and there wouldn't be a single
fuckin' bodyguard anywhere.
- I dunno, maybe it's just
like a thing of they're like,
"All right, well we have
some guests this year.
None of them are super high profile.
I guess we can scale it
back, save some money."
But obviously, you know.
And also, a lot of these cons,
they know YouTubers are big.
They know it, but they don't like,
they don't know it, right? (chuckles)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- They understand, "Oh,
yes, 3 million subs,"
but they're like,
"Yeah, but we have the guy who voices
in 'The Fairly Oddparents,' here.
And I know what that is.
And I don't know who this Trash guy is.
Who's these rubbish rubbish boys?"
- The rubbish lads.
- Yeah, who's these rubbish lads?
(Garnt laughing)
What are they?
So there's this complete...
Like a lot of cons do have
this kind of disconnect between like...
Because a lot of the
cons are ran by people
who understand older media
and traditional media,
they don't really understand
YouTubers that well.
They should buy now, but they don't.
And so I feel like
there's a lot of oversight
that happened there.
And then getting to
this guy in particular,
who came on the stage,
which was a weird thing,
'cause this guy didn't do
anything for the first 20 minutes.
- Yeah.
- And then started shouting.
- Everyone thought he
was like just a heckler.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I thought he was a heckler,
'cause I was just like,
"We've all dealt with
hecklers in the past as well."
- [Joey] Yeah, of course.
- So, someone asked a question,
and then I just like heard
someone shouting something
in like the fuckin'
background and something,
and I'm just like, "Oh, okay, it's-"
- Yeah, just ignore 'em. It's whatever.
- Passionate anime fans, I've
heard it all before, you know?
And then suddenly I see some guy
just walking up to the
stage, and I'm just like,
"Is this happening?"
- Yeah.
- Is this happening?
- I heard like a guy go,
"No, no I'm coming on."
And I was just like, "What?"
And then, someone stood
up, and I was like,
"What the fuck? Someone's coming up."
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I was like, "Oh no worries,
security will deal with it."
- Yeah. (laughing)
- Yeah, it was like,
"There'll be someone there."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was just like, "Okay,
he'll get to the stage.
Oh no, he's on the stage.
Well, he'll get near the sofa.
Oh no, he's near the sofa.
Oh, oh, he's sitting next to Joey."
And then I remember just like just waiting
because I assumed that
there would be someone
who would've come on and-
- I mean, like someone's
coming from backstage.
He's gonna come and collect him.
- I was like, "Backstage?"
No, I was like, "No, no one on the sides.
Um, what did we do?"
- And a good like 30,
40 seconds passed where nothing happened.
- Even the crowd was
like, "Is this a bit?"
Like, "What's happening?"
- Yeah, it was so like out of left field
that I talked to some
people, and originally,
they thought that it
was just a special guest
that had come on.
- A special guest. (chuckles)
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
- A special guest.
- Just a random dude, yeah.
- Yeah, just a bit in like
our show or something.
And we were just like,
I think the best way
to describe it is just,
we were just shell shocked.
- Yeah.
I mean, it was definitely
traumatizing, that's for sure.
'Cause that's like, yeah, as
I said, it was unprecedented.
Like that's never happened at any,
probably never any of our panels, right?
- [Garnt and Connor] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah, so it's just like-
- I dunno how calm we looked on camera,
but I'm pretty sure
internally, we were freaking
the fuck out.
- Oh, I was shitting myself.
'Cause I was like...
This dude like sat right next to me,
like he kinda like shoved me
outta the way 'cause I sitting
kind of in the middle
of the couch like this,
and he like shoved me out of the way.
And then, he like, I mean,
everyone who was there saw it,
but he tried to like
grab the mic off my hand.
- I saw that.
- Yeah, 'cause he wanted
to say something, and I
was like, "Ah, no, dude,"
like, "What the fuck are you doing?"
And then, yeah,
he just like starts rambling
off about something,
I don't even what the fuck.
- But he wasn't even
like being coherent.
- No, but it was just
like coming into one ear
and out the other
'cause I was just fuckin'
looking around like,
"Ah, is anyone gonna do
anything about this?"
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like I remember what he was
talking about was nothing to do
with what the question was asked
or what we were talking about before.
- He was just completely out of his mind.
- He was just rambling on
about something completely incoherent.
And meanwhile, Joey is
frantically looking around,
trying to find-
- Joey, (chuckles) I
felt really bad for you.
You were like, "Anyone? Anyone?"
- I was like, "Help."
Because I didn't wanna be the one
to like instigate something.
'Cause I don't know, the dude
might have a knife, you know?
The dude might suddenly
fuckin' swing at me.
So it's like, "I don't know what to do."
I can't like push him off or anything
'cause he was also fuckin' massive.
- Yeah, this guy was big.
- Yeah, big guy.
- I mean, I not saying that I would punch
if like a fuckin' two-foot
man came on the stage,
but like I'd be a lot more
lightly just to be like,
to try and leverage
(Garnt laughing)
my own position if they were-
- If a child comes onto
stage, you're like,
"Okay, baby."
- Just stand up
for the drop, kid.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- Well, it was just like,
you're in the situation,
someone comes up, and you
look at him, and you're like,
"If this guy really wanted
to swing for any of us,
odds are it's gonna fuckin'
like really fuckin' hurt. "
And I probably wouldn't
be able to punch him.
Like he was really tall and big.
So it's just like, you just sit there,
and you're like weighing your odds.
You're like, "What do I need to do?
What's the best way to handle this?"
Like I'm processing,
processing, processing.
- Yeah, 'cause you rarely find yourself
in a situation like this
where you don't know what
the outcome is going to be,
so in your head you are just like,
"What's the worst outcome
this could possibly be
and how could I prepare for it?"
'Cause you're kind of in
like fight or flight mode
at that point, right?
- Yeah, and also, it's like,
there was that like side of me as well
that was like, okay, say for example,
like if I fuckin' tripped him up
as he was like trying to flee,
and he like smashes his head in,
and he's gonna Amber Heard me
and like try and sue me
for defamation and damages.
(Garnt laughing)
I was like, "I didn't want that either."
So it's like, I literally
couldn't do anything,
and I just had to sit there and be like,
just prayge that way
someone would help me.
- I was just like hoping, I was, "Okay."
Obviously, a lot of people were like,
"Man, you should've just like
punched him or something,"
and it's like, "Well, it's like,
I don't wanna be the one to escalate it."
At the end of the day,
we're still on stage,
and we are trying-
- Bro, Creator Clash was like a month ago.
- Yeah, dude.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
- That's not what they
paid the money for, man.
- It's just like you're sitting there,
and you have to like go through it.
I'm like, "All right, well
what does this guy want?
Why is he on stage?"
And so, initially, I was just like,
"Okay, maybe he just wants to be funny."
And I was like,
"Well, this is great 'cause
I can handle cringe."
Like half of my videos
on my channel are like,
try not to cringe challenges.
And like I'm fine dealing with a guy
trying to be funny on stage.
I'll just outweighed him in cringe.
Like I know that I can sit here,
and if this guy was trying
to be funny, which he wasn't,
but if he was, I was like, "It's fine.
I'll just wait until he
feels so unbearably awkward
that he'll just leave."
And then I'll be like, "All right, good,"
which is what I think happened
eventually. (chuckles)
But this guy was completely, you know,
he was not in the right state of mind,
like this guy was clearly unwell.
- And he was also doing it
to a bunch of other panels as well.
So he clearly wasn't
like a targeted thing.
He was just like going around,
just wreaking as much havoc as possible.
- So yeah, what I heard
was, I don't know how...
Again, this is not 100% confirmed,
but this is the story that I was told.
Apparently he did this to another stage.
- After ours.
- Oh, after ours? Oh shit,
I thought it was before.
- No, no, no,
it was after ours.
- Oh, so, after ours.
And then, they tried to get him removed,
but at the time, they didn't
'cause for some reason they
didn't listen to the person
who was trying to get
him removed or something.
It was like a whole thing.
And then, yeah, we were told the next day
that he was arrested
afterwards, and I think charged,
I don't know what with, but apparently,
they went and asked him why-
- Being cringe.
- Yeah, why he did it. Yeah, cringe.
(all laughing)
Sentenced to-
- Sentenced to jail for being cringe.
- Sentenced to die of cringe.
(Garnt laughing)
- I sentence you for being cringe.
(all laughing)
- Honestly.
- So what are you in for?
I was cringe at a con.
(all laughing)
- I dunno. Maybe like
trespassing or some stuff.
I don't fuckin' know.
Either way, I mean, glad
that something happened.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They caught him and
asked him why he did it.
He said something along
the lines of, yeah,
he apparently just
wanted to go up on stage.
Like he didn't really know who we were.
He was just there trying
to get on stage to things.
So it was just unfortunate timing
that it was a guy at our panel
who just wanted to jump on stage.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well, it could have been
anyone at the end of the day.
- We're lucky it turned out well.
If that guy really wanted to do something,
this could be a really different story.
- I mean, I see it as
a positive experience
because it really-
(Connor laughing)
- Sure.
- Do you wanna be in my seat
and say that or? (laughs)
- Sure. (laughs) Okay, okay, okay.
Let me say, I see it
as an event like this,
where something this big happened
and nothing bad came out of it,
it really put things
into perspective for us.
- Oh yeah.
- It made it guaranteed
that something like this
isn't gonna happen again
because now we are more aware of it.
Now we're gonna convey
this to wherever we go to.
So I think, it's obviously not
a good thing that happened,
and maybe we should have
been more prepared for it,
but it did happen.
Nothing too bad came out of
it, aside from just seeing-
- A lot of cringe.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
And just like getting his ass
flashed in front of our face,
because his trousers
were like half way down.
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
- It wasn't even like a half crack.
Like he might as well have
not been wearing pants.
It was like the full ass crack.
And I was like, "Oh, God, why? Why?"
Also he stank,
like he really fuckin' stank.
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
I was like, "Holy shit,
you definitely smell like a
con goer, that's for sure."
- I just fuckin' hope that
guy gets the help he needs.
'cause he's clearly fuckin' unwell.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was like, I dunno,
it was just fucked.
It sucked as well 'cause
halfway through, we had to...
The panel, it was going
okay at that point, I'd say,
and then we were already kind of like,
"Fuck, dude, we gotta do this
panel now after that happened,
like pretend like nothing happened.
- At least if it was
like near the beginning
or near the end, then it'd
be a little bit easier
to kind of just like clean
it up and get over it,
but it was like dead set
in the middle of the panel.
So it was like the hardest
to kind of recuperating,
like get back onto the flow of things.
- 'Cause I remember I tried
to like continue the panel
and the only image that was in my mind
was just that ass-
- That ass. (laughs)
- that bare ass crack.
That bare ass crack just like
hypnotized me to be like,
"Whoa, where am I right now?"
- For me, it was that.
And also, just like in the
back of my head being like,
"What if someone else also does this?"
Like what if like another
person is just like,
"Well, they didn't fuckin' do anything,
now it's my time to get
15 minutes of fame."
So I was like so fuckin' scared for that.
And it's like...
And also, I was just like, "Oh good,
I'm gonna see this all over the subreddit
and the Twitter feed in like
17 different fuckin' angles."
But yeah, it was whatever.
Again, the silver lining
is that now we know,
now we're gonna be a little
more prepared for future cons
and future events and stuff like that.
- Nobody got hurt.
- Yeah, nobody got hurt.
- That's the important thing.
- Exactly.
Just a lot of trauma and a lot of cringe.
- Just a lot-
- Just a lot
of emotional damage.
- of torture,
drama by cringe,
basically.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- Emotional damage, but no
physical damage, so that's good.
(Garnt laughing)
- Aside from the panel,
how else was your guys' kind experience?
- Yeah, it was good.
- Yeah, I mean the signing
was freakin' awesome.
That was a good thing,
at least like everyone
who came to the signing
was super nice, super respectful,
lots of like really cool
artists and stuff like that.
I just like kind of wish I had enough time
to go to the Artist Alley
'cause I feel MCMs Artist
Alley was really freakin' good
compared to like other
cons that I've been to.
'Cause like naturally
when you're at signing,
a lot of people bring up
stuff that they bought
at the Artist Alley.
- Oh, I saw some of the stuff
from the Artist Alley.
- Some of the stuff
I was genuinely like, "Where
the hell did you get that?"
'Cause I wanna get it.
But unfortunately, we
didn't have enough time
to go to the Artist Alley this year,
so that was a little
disappointing, but, you know.
- Well, It was kind of hard to walk around
in general this year, I feel like.
Because I feel like the
last convention we went to,
it was like AX 2019, and we've said that
we could still walk around
the convention, right?
- Yeah.
- Like we get stopped every now and again,
especially at a event like AX.
But it wasn't to the point
where it completely stops your movement
and like made it so you
couldn't walk around.
And I felt like that was very,
very different this year.
- Yeah, like I didn't even bother trying,
especially after I heard
what Connor tried to do.
- (laughing) Oh my God.
- I knew you were gonna fuckin' tell.
- (laughing) We've got to.
We've got to.
- (laughing) It's just so-
- It's so funny.
So like after the panel
and after our signing...
Was it after the signing?
- It was after the signing.
- Okay, so after the signing,
like our day was free,
and we had like a good two, three hours
to enjoy the convention.
- We were like up in the
green room right after.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. So,
we're up in the green room.
And normally, at this
point, we're just like,
"Great, we've got two, three
hours to enjoy the convention.
Let's just walk around
and stuff like that."
But like seeing how many
people were at our signing
and seeing how many people
couldn't even make it
to our signing because
the signing got cut off.
The line was like full
capacity like an hour or two
even before we started the signing.
I'm like-
- Yeah, I felt bad to everyone
who wanted the signature.
Sorry.
- Yeah, really sorry.
- We would've done it if we could've.
- We would've done it if
there was enough time,
but unfortunately-
- Yeah,
I think we were signing for
like two and a half hours,
and that was like capping
the line two hours
before the line even opened.
But yeah, so I got the feeling
that probably not a good idea
to walk around, especially
without security.
And Connor was just
like, "Guys, I got this.
I got the perfect disguise."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
So let me tell you what
Connor's disguise was.
So, so let me tell you
what con's disguise was.
like a normal COVID surgical
face mask and some sunglasses.
- And a hat.
- This is genius.
- So, first things first,
wearing sunglasses inside,
totally inconspicuous.
No one's gonna look at you at all.
- Absolutely.
- Why would you be
wearing sunglasses inside?
- It was bright.
- Second, that he forgot
that the shirt he was wearing
was a Trash t-shirt.
- That hasn't been
released yet. (laughing)
- I know, yeah.
It was a Trash t-shirt that
hasn't been shipped out
to the general public yet, so. (laughing)
- Listen, I-
- Also, it's the Trash
t-shirt that you see him wear
in almost every video
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
and every episode.
So it's like that shirt
has just been synonymous.
Look, like, yep, that's Connor's shirt.
- I wanted to say hi
to some of my friends,
so I was like, "Hey, I'll
just come quickly and say hi."
I wasn't gonna stay out long.
I was just gonna say hi.
And obviously, I knew it
wasn't a full-proof disguise.
I wasn't fuckin' going
to film any movie scenes
fooling anybody.
I was just like, "Maybe
it'll just buy me enough time
where people will double glance,
and then I can just walk away," right?
- [Garnt And Joey] Right.
- So I was like, "Okay, let's-"
- And how far did you get?
- Well, no, so I went to meet my friend
who I told to come meet
me like at the gate.
So it was like, I literally
walked out like two meters,
and there my friend was.
Problem was that at this area
that was really convenient for me,
people were waiting for
Sydney, signed Sydney stuff.
And obviously,
people were waiting around
there and recognized,
so people just started
coming up to you right away.
But I was trying to talk to my friends,
and it was just really
fuckin' annoying. (chuckles)
'Cause I was just like, "Hold on a second.
I'm just talking to my
friend, give me a moment."
And then they were like
just asking for photos.
And then the moment I turned
around to like go back,
there was like five people on this side.
And then because my friend
left, who I was talking to,
people just filled the
void, and I was like,
"Oh, shit, I'm getting surrounded."
(Garnt laughing)
So, the people in front of me,
I just quickly took a picture
with them, and I was like,
"Make this fast, please, please."
And then the people behind me,
I could just feel them be
like, "Connor, Connor,"
and I was like, "I've gotta go.
I gotta go. I'm so sorry."
'Cause if I start doing
all of them, I won't-
- It just never ends.
- Yeah, I won't stop, and it sucks.
It's like, "I have to go."
Like, "I'm sorry that I wasn't
able to give you a picture."
- That is the most like suffering
from success story ever.
- But it sucks, right?
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
It's like, friends would be like,
"Oh, come hang out, I'm over here."
I'm like, "I'm sorry, I can't walk there."
And they're like, "Oh wow,
okay, you're too big, huh?"
I'm like, "Literally, yes."
Like, "I actually can't walk to you."
This will be a miserable
experience if I walk near you.
- Like it's literally not even us
trying to like humble brag.
It's just like the truth.
- No, no, no, no.
- It was just like this
was the eye-opening weekend
for us to see like, "Oh, okay,
now we have to consider things
that we've never had to consider before."
- Don't get me wrong,
we're greatly appreciative.
- We're very grateful,
but obviously-
Yeah, we fuckin' love it,
but, you know.
- I mean like 'cause after a signing,
I really, really wanted
to go to Sydney's panel.
- Right, right, right.
'Cause her panel wasn't on the main stage.
It was on like one of like the side stages
that was like in the
middle of the convention.
- It was kinda like a two
or three-minute walk, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it was like a two or three-minute walk
through like this crowd.
And I remember asking one
of the handlers, like,
"Can I go see Sydney's panel?"
'Cause it was our first panel.
I'm like, "I wanna see my girl, man.
Where's my girl?
Where's my girl?"
- Of course, of course.
- And they were like, "I don't
think that's a good idea.
You should not be walking
through that crowd."
Like they literally were just like, "No.
After what has happened on
stage, we cannot stop you,
but we highly, highly," and
they're like begging me,
"Please don't go."
(Joey laughing)
'Cause I could see like the
sweat drop on their face.
Like being like, "Oh, if he
says yes, I can't deny him,
but I don't wanna deal
with like the consequence
of it happening."
(chuckling) 'Cause actually
like, so on the second day,
so on the Sunday, we were
hanging out at one of the bars.
It was like the Novotel,
which is like far enough
from the convention
that it's like not too many people there,
but close enough that you could walk
to and from the convention.
So I was hanging out there
with a few of my mates
on like the Sunday, and it was like,
everyone was still in the convention,
so it was like pretty dead.
And so you guys had your signings,
So I wanted to meet you guys
in the green room or whatever.
And so once the con ends,
your guys' signing ends,
so I'm like, "Great, let's go meet up."
And I said, "Oh, okay,
I'll go to the hotel
that we were staying at,"
which we had to go to the
other side of the convention.
And I remember going out with my mate
to see the optimal path
to walk to the hotel
that we're going to.
And what it felt like, I walk outside,
and everyone started to go
outside to the big grassy area,
because the convention's over now,
so you just see like this massive crowd.
And what it felt like is,
you know like in that fuckin' zombie movie
where they're on like
the roof of the mall?
- Yeah.
- And they have to get like the food,
and they see like the crowd of zombies
that they have to walk through.
- Literally, like the
opening scene to Dead Rising.
- Yeah, (laughs) that's what it felt like.
'Cause I'm just like, (sighs)
"Okay, let me plan on my route.
What's like the most
optimal route I can walk
without like...
What's the least possibility
I could be stopped.
- Grab the bench and start swinging.
(Garnt laughing)
It's like, "Outta the
way! I need to get food!"
I get my baseball bat out.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Oh my God.
- It's just short of
"The Dead" or something.
- My God, yeah.
I mean, like a lot of things
happened this weekend,
but I think all in all,
it was a positive experience, I'd say.
This episode is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
- Guys, how much time do you
spend on your phone nowadays?
- All the time.
- And what'd you guys do on your phone?
- Just browse on the web.
- The scary part is
that your phone carrier
collects all the data on
whatever you're doing.
Verizon even admitted it!
- What?!
- Oh, God!
- They say it's so that you
can get a better understanding
of your interests.
But really, all they wanna do
is sell your activities to advertisers.
The more they can get on you,
the larger the paycheck becomes,
which is why I use ExpressVPN.
- ExpressVPN is the app that
prevents your phone carrier
from being able to see the sites you visit
and sell it off to third parties.
All it takes is one tap of a button,
and all of your network data
gets encrypted and rerouted
through ExpressVPN secure
servers for ultimate privacy.
Not only does it shield your web browsing,
ExpressVPN protects all
of your network data,
so you can stay private even
when using your favorite apps.
And the best part is one
subscription can be used
for up to five devices at the same time.
I have my whole family using ExpressVPN.
I don't have a family, but if I did,
they would all be on ExpressVPN!
- Take back your online privacy today,
ladies and gentlemen,
by using expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
That's expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
The link's in the description below.
Back to the episode.
- It was cool and weird having bodyguards.
We got bodyguards on the last day.
- Oh yeah!
- Yeah, yeah,
we certainly did.
- Obviously, what happened on Saturday,
which is the main panel,
and Garnt getting shot
by a Nerf gun and stuff.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They kind of were like,
"All right, we will step this up a lot."
And then they went like...
They gave props to MCM
for doing it.
- Above and beyond, yeah.
- We had like-
- They went above and beyond.
- (chuckles) four fuckin'
bodyguards with us.
It was so, I felt excessive,
but I appreciate it.
Had a really nice guy,
you know, he was really
chill, who would speak to me.
And then it was really
strange going in in the toilet
and just coming out of the toilet,
and he's just like waiting for me.
And I'm like, "Okay, this is
weird," but it makes sense.
It was cool.
You know, he was very professional.
I see why people don't mind having one,
'cause I thought it was
gonna be really overbearing
having someone behind you,
but he was really nice.
He just kind like stood back,
and whenever he felt
anything was happening,
he would just kind of
introduce himself or not.
He would just kinda step up a little.
- Yeah, just kinda interject a little bit.
- Yeah, it was really
good. I mean it was nice.
Definitely, we learned that
we have to get it now for AX,
I guess.
- For AX,
and like future conventions
that we're going to.
Yeah, like I said, this is
like our first convention
since starting Trash
Taste, and now we know.
This has like set the
presidents, precedence, for us.
- President.
- That word's really given
you a lot of trouble.
- It is, it is, it is.
- The president, Mr. President.
- Set the standard for us
is what I'm saying.
- Yeah, definitely.
- But I mean, I still had
a great time, actually.
- No, it was awesome.
Like I said, everyone was super nice.
Like getting to see people after so long
has been like crazy.
- Just reminding you
that great people exist.
- Yeah, man.
- You know, just like seeing everyone,
seeing the gifts that
we've been given as well.
- So many fuckin' talented
artists and stuff as well.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- I think my favorite gift
that was given to all of us, actually,
was there was this like
wooden Trash Taste plaque,
and it was like perfectly crafted.
I'm just like, there was such
great craftsmanships on it.
I'm like, "Oh, this looks amazing."
And I remember gorping at it with Joey,
and we were just admiring
like the craftmanship.
And then, we turn it around, and it says,
"Lick my balls."
- Lick my balls.
(all laughing)
And we're both just like, "Damn!"
- He got gonged.
(Grant laughing)
Someone gave me these cards,
and I found them in my pocket earlier.
And one, it just says, "Hamon,
Lord of Striking Thunder."
- Oh yeah, those are
Yu-Gi-Oh cards, right?
- Yeah, I didn't know,
there was Hamon in Yu-Gi-Oh.
- Yeah, there is, yeah.
- Why is there Hamon in Yu-Gi-Oh?
- I don't know.
- This one is "Raviel, Lord of Phantasms."
I didn't really understand why
that one was relevant to me.
- I think Hamon is my one, actually.
- What? You're Hamon?
- I wonder why you have it.
Yeah.
- What the fuck?
- Yeah, I was given Hamon.
- I want Hamon, dude.
(Garnt laughs)
Someone just gave me a Yu-Gi-Oh card.
I don't know, I had it in my pocket.
- I think they gave one for Garnt as well,
but it must be in the bag of stuff.
- Yeah, I guess. Wow, it was cool.
- So yeah, thank you to
everyone who showed up
and gave gifts and signing
and the panel and all that.
It was really, really cool. Really cool.
- Would you guys think
about getting masks to wear
for like future conventions
and stuff like that?
A better disguise
than what you have?
- No, dude.
That was a solid disguise, dude.
- Now, do you wanna talk about
the disguise you were
thinking of having? (laughing)
- Okay, okay, okay. You know what?
After seeing what happened
on the second day,
I call up my mates, who
was on like the floor,
and I was like, "Can you buy me a mask?"
'Cause I wanna see if like the mask works.
- Like a full?
- Like a full face mask.
And so, they buy me a mask.
I'm not gonna say what it
is in case I end up using it
for future conventions,
but they buy me a mask of a character.
That's that's all I'm going to say.
And so, we go to the bar afterwards,
they bring me the masks, and
I try it on in front of Joey.
And I'm like, "Joey, does
this mask work at all?
Can you tell it's me?"
And the first thing Joey says is like,
"You ain't tricking anyone."
- No, because it's like the
mask just covers the face.
Because Garnt's hair stands up,
it's just Garnt's hair above it.
Like, you can tell from...
If you are aware of what
Garnt's hair looks like,
it's so freaking obvious. I'm
like, "Yep, that's Garnt."
Yeah, because I knew
that wasn't gonna work
because back in AX 2018, 2019,
whichever the last one was,
Aki and I tried to do the same thing.
We didn't even have like a face mask.
We had like a full covering the head,
like balaclava-style mask.
And we were both wearing that,
we were like, "Yeah, we're
gonna get away with this."
They'll never freaking know."
And we were walking from
the hotel to the convention,
which was like a two or three-minute walk.
And as soon as I got out of
the hotel, someone was like,
"Hey, Joey."
(Garnt laughing)
I was just like, "Fuck it! Damn it!"
- My perfect disguise.
- It's like, I immediately gave up.
- Yeah.
- So, I don't think it's gonna work.
That's why I was laughing
also when Connor was like,
"They'll never know it's me."
- I didn't expect it to work.
I was like, "It'll just
buy me enough time."
- You might as well just
had a sign that says,
"I am Connor for Trash Taste."
(Garnt laughing)
- Just like a sign that says,
- I'll do that.
- "I am not Connor."
- I am not Connor.
(Garnt laughing)
- I'll do that on the next show.
We'll get a giant fuckin',
like one of those pizza
flipping sign things?
- Yeah, "I'm not Connor."
- I'll be like,
an arrow here that's
like, "I am not Connor."
(Garnt laughing)
- 'Cause I actually
did try it on a Sunday,
and it worked for a bit, actually.
It worked, yeah.
- Really?
- 'Cause like people would
definitely recognize me.
Like as I was walking
around the convention,
people would definitely recognize me,
but it wasn't like...
It was like Connor's trap,
well, what Connor wanted to do,
which was it bought you enough time
that they didn't like...
You didn't get stopped immediately,
but I could see like every
fifth person I walked past,
they did like the double take.
They did like the double take.
They would walk past and then
like something would click,
and then they just like, "Is that?"
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Who was that guy?
- Yeah, who was that guy?
I felt a disturbance in the
force for a second there,
but like that bought me
enough time to be like,
"Okay, they've looked around,
and I'm already like enough the way down."
- [Connor And Joey] Yeah.
- So, it definitely
didn't hide my identity,
but it made people
not immediately recognize me.
- Like not run up
from a distance kinda like, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And I think like as long as
you don't stop in one place
for too long, then it's useful.
- But the problem with that is that like
if you have that particular
mask on, for instance,
then the word is going to spread.
So it's gonna be like,
"Yeah, so the guy in that
mask, yeah, that's Garnt."
And then it just doesn't work anymore
because it's like,
now they're just looking
for the guy in that mask.
- [Garnt] Yeah, right.
- So it's like, it's a one trick pony.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
You gotta get like a
new mask for every day
or every fuckin' convention
(Joey laughing)
or something. (chuckles)
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, 'cause I did see like
a couple of people I knew,
like YouTubers and stuff,
who were going in like
cosplay, and stuff like that.
And I'm like, "Okay, that's smart
because you're in a full
cosplay type of thing.
- [Garnt] Exactly.
- So it's not just like
covering the head type of thing,
but like in saying that,
am I bothered to get like a full
or my full body cosplay
to like walk around?
No, I'm not.
- It's too hot.
- Yeah.
- It is, it's too hot.
- Speaking of cosplay, though,
my God, Genshin has like
taken over this year.
Oh my God.
- Yeah.
- Like every third cosplayer
I saw was a Genshin character.
- Yeah, yeah, 'cause normally I remember
like the anime con experience
is like one or two characters
would completely take over.
Now, it was just like the
entire cast of Genshin.
- Yeah, there's a lot of Genshin.
I didn't realize that it was that popular.
- That's right, 'cause I
remember in like 2018, 2019,
I think the big thing,
at least for people who
came up to my signing,
was like Nekopara characters.
And I think I saw like two
Nekopara characters today,
and I was like, "Oh, okay."
- Nekopara, was that big?
- Yeah, I mean, there was a lot
'cause it's so easy to cosplay, right?
- Yeah, I guess so.
- And it's like,
there's so many variations,
so like it's very easy for a
lot of people to cosplay it,
but yeah, now it's just
like Genshin or Demon Slayer
or there's something else.
- I saw a lot of Demon Slayer.
- Yeah.
- And there's always
gonna be a lot of-
- I was expecting that,
though.
- I was expecting
Demon Slayer.
- A lot of JuJutsu Kaisen as well.
- Yeah, of course.
- That was like
the big three that I saw.
- 'Cause it's not mid.
- Oh, yeah, because it's not mid,
apparently.
- It's not mid.
- Yeah, but like my mates were telling me
that like the Genshin line or
the line to buy Genshin merch
was like by far like the longest line.
- Oh, wow.
I didn't even know they
were selling Genshin merch.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
And I'm just like,
"Well, this is the closest
any Genshin fan is gonna get
to buying actual feel
real merch, you know?
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- But there was one part
of me that was like,
"Oh man, there's so
many Genshin characters
that have been cosplaying,
and it's like, "Oh yeah,
this is like a new era
of like cosplaying at cons."
But the one thing where I was like,
"Oh yeah, this will never change,"
is people coming up to me
making me sign Death Notes.
- Oh, yeah.
- Ah!
- I was like, "That is
a piece of con culture
that will probably never go away."
- That will never go away.
And I'm like, "All right,
that's familiar right there."
(Joey laughing)
- Fuck, I just remembered that
happened to me as well, yeah.
- I probably signed like
10 or 20 Death Notes
like during this week.
And I was like,
"All right, that's one
piece of like con culture,
I'm glad will never go away.
- It's like gotten to the point
where I know the notebook now
when I get given it, right?
(Joey laughing)
Because they make it like you
always get the Death Note,
and then they make you sign it,
and then they're like, "Close the cover,"
and they're like staring at you.
You know, they're like,
"Ha, what do you think?"
And I'm just like, "Haha, you got me!"
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, the pages are very noticeable.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- It's like, I don't know,
you're not fooling anyone.
- I don't even have to
like flip the cover anymore
to see what I'm saying.
I'm just like, "Yeah, that's death."
- Are you superstitious about it?
I know some people don't sign Death Notes
'cause they're like, "Oh,
what if I actually do die?"
- What? Who?
- I've met some people
who don't sign them.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Oh.
- Ah.
- 'Cause like, "Are you
wishing me to die or something?
That's fucked up."
- No, I don't care.
- Ah, I mean, like also another thing
is like there's a lot of people
that try to get you in Deez
Nuts strokes nowadays as well.
That's the new like Death
Note, like trick now.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's like I had a couple
of people being like,
"Oh, can you sign this for my friend?
He couldn't be here because he had ligma."
And I'm like this close to being like,
"Oh, I'm sorry for your friend." (laughs)
And I had to stop myself.
I mean, I was like, "Mmm." (chuckles)
- Yeah, I think this guy
tried it on all three of us.
And I think I was first, and
I was like, "All right, nice."
I was like, "Ligma, okay, wow."
(Garnt laughing)
I was like, "Come on, man.
Do you really think that's
gonna fuckin' work?"
Come on,
find something creative.
- Although, I must say
that the dude who found
that restaurant in London,
which was called Secundus.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think that was genius.
- I was like, "All
right, you deserve that.
You deserve the grit.
- That's like a Deez Nuts stroke
that had effort put into it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I respect that
'cause he got us these like
Indian, or I think like-
- Indian nuts or something.
- Yeah, it was like a snack
that was made outta nuts.
So it was like, "Oh, I got
you some nuts from Secundus."
I was like, "Okay, that's kind of funny."
(Garnt laughing)
That was really funny.
- It's like, "I'll take it. I'll take it."
- I was like, "You know what?
I respect the creativity, I'll take that."
- What were some of the
gifts that you guys got?
Was there anything that stood out?
- Oh, there was one.
Actually, we got it yesterday.
But there was this guy, this artist guy,
who gave us this like poster,
and he's like a mecha artist.
And he made this like-
- Maybe it's on screen.
- Maybe it's on screen. I don't know.
But like he made this like
Trash Taste mecha, essentially.
- [Connor] Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, and it's like full on.
- It looked-
- Connor,
- really fuckin' good.
- you saw it, right?
It looked freaking amazing.
It was like kind of a cross
between a Gundam and an Ava type of thing,
but it was like, it had like
the Trash Taste purple on it.
And it looked really freaking cool.
And it was like,
- It was really good.
- "Yeah, I did it in two days."
And I was like, "What the hell?"
I wish I could do that.
(Garnt laughing)
- It was really nice.
- I really wanted to give it to Alan
'cause I know he is like
a massive mecha head.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so I've like held onto it,
so I'll give it to Alan.
- That's really cool.
- But I wanna see that.
- Yeah, there was just like
so many cool, I don't know,
really talented people.
Like a girl gave me a ring
that she had like made as well.
- That sounds so cool.
- Brilliant.
Yeah.
And yeah, I don't know,
obviously, pieces of fan
art and stuff like that
is like amazing as well.
And like, we've kept all of it obviously.
- I got like a custom Pokemon card
for mine and Sydney's wedding.
It was like custom-made.
- Oh really? Shoot.
- It was like proper metal and everything.
I was like-
- Oh, cool.
- That's pretty fuckin' cool.
- that was one of the
coolest gifts I've gotten.
- I remember there was a guy
who came to my signing on the Friday,
and he made me sign
like Holo Yu-Gi-Oh card.
and I was like, "Oh, that's really cool.
I haven't seen that in a long time."
He came back on the
Sunday to give me the card
in film like this.
- What the fuck?
- It was like,
"Yeah, I like scoured it
all over the continent
and like find it for you."
And he like came back on
the Sunday to give it to me,
and I was just like, "You've
achieved, bro! (chuckles)
You've achieved!"
- Give me a limited edition
first (indistinct) please.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- I would like one.
- Did you get someone...
Did you get a masterpiece?
- Oh, no.
So yeah, the guy, I was
really disappointed,
he brought out a copy of "Master Piece,"
which is like-
- The Hentai.
- Yeah, the Hentai. It was
like the full doujin colored.
And I was like, "Oh my God."
He said, "Yeah, sign it for me."
And I'm like, "Can I have
it?" And he was like, "No."
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
And I was like, "Hey,
I gotta shoot my shot."
- It's like, "Oh, you got this for me!"
"No, just sign it bitch!"
- It was like a joke.
I was like joking with him,
like, "You got this for me, right?"
And he was like, "No."
And I'm like, "I think
you've got it for me."
(all laughing)
And then, this poor guy behind,
so we had like, obviously, you
have like a handler at a con,
basically the handler's job
is to just kind of get you
to where you need to go
and also help with the signings,
kind of help with the flow.
And he was like this normal
British dude who just like,
he was talking me about
football and stuff.
And I pretended like I
understood what was going on.
And (chuckles) I take out
this masterpiece to sign it,
and I just open it up, and
I'm like, "Nice, nice."
And he's like, "Whoa!"
(Garnt laughing)
Whoa! And I'm like, "Oh
yeah, this is not normal."
This is not a normal thing to open
and just admire right now.
And so I closed it, and
I was like, "All right."
He was like, "Wow, that
was intense, wasn't it?"
I was like, "Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah."
Fuckin' wierdo, right? Wierdo.
Freak! What a freak, dude!
- No, I totally just like bought into it
because like my handler
who was next to me,
she was just like,
"Oh, yeah, you've signed
some pretty weird things."
And I'm like, "You haven't
seen anything yet."
And then, literally, as I
said that, some dude was like,
"Can I get you to sign something
that's like very questionable?"
And I was like, "All right, here we go,"
and he pulls out like a Sasuke X Naruto,
like yaoi doujin.
- I signed that as well.
- And he was like...
And I was like, "Where do
you want me to sign it,
like on the cover and stuff like that?"
And he's like, "No, open it up
and find the most fucked
up page to sign it on.
And I was like,
"I don't wanna open this
in front of my handler
(Garnt laughing)
being like, 'Oh, wonder where's
the most fucked up scene.'"
And then, I did find the most
up scene, and I was like,
"All right, I'll do it right there."
And she was just like, "No judging.
You know what? These
are your fans, I guess."
And I was like, "Yeah." (chuckles)
(Garnt laughing)
I remember, like I had a similar
experience, because okay,
we've talked a lot about MCM.
I always say like the signing experience
was like the smoothest signing
experience I've ever had-
- [Joey] Yeah, definitely.
- at any convention.
They had this shit on lockdown,
like it was like in and out,
in and out, take your stuff.
They gave us like a post note
of like what they wanted us to sign,
what the person's name was.
It was like excellent.
- It was so streamlined.
- Yeah, it was so streamlined.
I remember the first one,
the first SAS one that I got,
it was a manga called,
like I think like "Dick
Fight Island" or something.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, I think I remember that.
- I know the lot.
- It was "Dick Fight
Island," and I was just like,
"Oh, what's this?"
And he goes like, "Oh,
Sydney recommended it."
And I was just like,
"That sounds
like Sydney recommendation."
- Of course, she did.
- And he just goes off on like,
he just starts going off
on like the entire synopsis
Of "Dick Fight Island,"
which is apparently just a
bunch of dudes on an island,
and they fight with their dicks.
And that's what I'm guessing is it.
But he goes into it in
like such graphic detail.
And so I'm like,
"Yeah, that sounds like a really,
really interesting story."
I sign it, he goes away,
and we had like a little
five-minute breather.
And my handler goes to
me, "So, what do you do?"
(all laughing)
- It's a long story.
- I'm like, "How do I explain this?"
- You should have just been like,
"Yes, I'm the author
of "Dick Fight Island."
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Oh, you know what, actually,
I got someone came out
to me who is like...
This is like referenced, I guess,
to anyone who has watched
this episode of Trash Taste.
He was like, 2Oh man, I love your work."
And then he just gives me
a copy of "Goblin Slayer."
(Garnt chuckling)
And I was like-
- Did he actually?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And he was like, "Oh, can you sign it?"
And I was like, "Yeah, dude, let's do it."
(all laughing)
So I signed a "Goblin Slayer."
- Oh my God.
- Hell, yeah.
- Oh God, that was interesting.
Yeah, I mean, there was
a lot of normal things.
Everyone thinks that like
they're gonna hand you
the weirdest thing.
They're like,
"Oh, I'm gonna go show you
something really out there."
And it's like, "All right,
I've signed everything."
And I love how it's those
people who are always like,
"Oh, I'm sorry, you've never
signed anything this weird."
And I was just like (chuckles) no idea.
(Connor laughing)
- This is baby mode right now.
- Yeah, this is baby mode, dude.
- So, did anything else
notable happen to you
at the convention?
- Ah, I dunno. Did anything?
I got to see a lot of people
I haven't seen in years,
which was nice.
- Did you guys get recognized anywhere,
like at a weird place that
was not in the convention?
- Oh, I got...
'Cause the hotel they put us in
was like literally like the Connor Hotel.
So anyone who was going to the con
was staying in this hotel.
- Yeah.
- And like I'm in the
elevator, sorry, lift.
(Garnt laughs)
- Wow, you've changed. You've changed.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I've changed. So I
got on the lift, right?
And there's this guy, and he's like,
"Oh wow, you're CDawg, right?"
And I'm like, "Yeah. Hi, what's up?"
And he's like, "Can I have a picture?"
I'm like, "Yeah, sure,
let's do it. Let's do."
So like I'm taking a
picture with this guy,
and he's like trying
to get his phone ready,
and he's like giving
stuff to his girlfriend
or whoever this is.
And his girlfriend's like,
"Honey, who is this guy?"
And he's like, "You know, it's CDawg."
And she's like, "All right."
And he's like, "Yeah, I
used to watch his videos."
(Garnt laughs)
- So it's such a backhanded compliment.
- Bro, that's a bro moment.
- That's a bro moment.
- And he said this to her and
looked at me and just smiled,
like, "Ready for the picture?"
And I'm like, "What the fuck?"
- Like Unravel, stars playing.
- Yeah.
- I used to watch his
pictures, I mean videos.
- I was like, "What the fuck, dude?"
(Garnt laughing)
- Where you just like, "What happened?"
- Yeah, I get it, maybe
you got busier and stuff.
But could you say that little later?
Why are you gonna say it to my face?
(Garnt laughs)
- [Joey] That's kinda like saying-
- Did you just get like L
plus ratio plus fell off.
- Yeah.
- This guy was like, "I
used to watch his videos,"
and then he just smiled at me.
And I was like, "What bro,
what do you mean 'used too'?"
- Well, I mean, I guess like
one notable thing was the panel
that we had on Sunday.
- Oh yeah, how did that
go? 'Cause I wasn't there.
- So the Saturday panel
was kind of like a Q&A
type of thing, right?
So it was like, there was
a microphone in the crowd,
people could come up
and ask the questions,
and we'd answered type of thing.
But the Sunday one, it was
like the title of it was
A Conversation with the Anime Man CDawgVA.
So we structured a kind of like...
It was me and Connor on the stage,
and then we kind of had
like an MC type of thing,
who was there to navigate
and ask general questions
to like get a flow of conversation going.
And because we asked this MC guy,
who was a great MC, mind you,
but it was very last minute.
And he obviously didn't
know who me and Connor were,
what we do.
He only knew like a very
baseline information.
So, obviously, a lot of the questions
were like very general,
but (chuckles) then
there was one question.
He was like something
along the lines of like,
"Yeah, I was an MC for your wife, Sidsnap.
(Garnt laughing)
And he was like looking straight at me.
- And I was like, "Ah,"
and I looked at Connor,
and we kind of like met eyes,
and I looked back at the MC,
I was like, "Could you repeat that?"
(all laughing)
He was like,
"Yeah, yeah, your fiance
and wife Sydney or Sidsnap,
she was telling me all these stories
about planning for the wedding
and all that kind of stuff.
And I was like,
and there was a murmur
happening in the crowd.
And I was like...
And I just like slowly pulled
my hand out, and I was like,
"I'm Joey, by the way,
nice to meet you."
(Garnt laughing)
And he was like, "No, no,
you're Grant or Garnt, right?"
And I was like, "Is this really happening?
Is accidental racism happening
live on stage right now?"
And I think people in the
crowd were kind of like,
"Ah, yeah, funny bit.
Got nice execution, nice landing guys."
And meanwhile, I'm just like,
"This motherfucker literally
confused me with Garnt."
Like, what? All Asians look the same now?
Is that how it is? (chuckles)
- Congratulations on getting
married to Sydney, by the way.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- Hope the wedding goes well. (chuckles)
- You know, I've been
planning for a while now.
You know how it is. Whew!
(Garnt laughing)
And I think Alan said it best last night,
he was like,
"Wow, I can't believe he
confused the Anime Zone
with the Anime Man.
(all laughing)
- Easy mistake, you know.
Easy mistake.
- It's an easy mistake.
- Easy mistake, yeah.
- It's like,
"Aw, when you put it that way,
it's fair enough."
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- None of you are watching anime, right?
- Well, he would love
us to watch an anime.
- I could sympathize with him.
He kinda got dragged to do it last minute.
- And I could tell when like...
And he was like trying to
double down on it on our cast.
- That was the thing where I was like,
"No, no, come on, dude."
(Garnt laughing)
He was like, "No, I'm sure
it was something, something."
- I'm like, "No, just move on, dude.
And then there was a
moment during the panel
where like people in the
crowd started to laugh
when he doubled down, and
just like wouldn't land.
And he just like put both
his hands in his face,
and he was just like, "Oh no,
I've made a horrible mistake."
And I was like-
- Aw-
"No, don't worry, man.
- I feel so bad.
- It's fine. It was funny."
It was funny and harmless,
and, you know, great
story for the podcast.
So I was like, "It's whatever."
Yeah, but other than that-
- Why are you Garnt?
(Joey laughing)
You are Garnt.
- I am not Garnt.
(Garnt laughing)
You are Garnt.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
Why are you Garnt?
- Oh, God.
- Yeah, but that was an interesting-
- I got somethin',
like I got recognized in
some interesting place.
Oh, (laughing) one funny thing
that happened actually was,
so, I got recognized by someone
and took a picture with them,
and they were like, "You're
not gonna believe this.
I saw the most convincing Sydney lookalike
I've ever seen in my life."
(Joey laughing)
I'm like, "Oh, okay, let me
see this. What's that like?
I wanna see if there's
a my wife lookalike.
- [Joey] Sidsnap is funny.
- He slightly like gets out's
phone, puts the picture on,
starts swiping like furiously.
And then he goes, "Look at that.
Does that not look like Sydney?"
And it's him standing next to Sydney.
(all laughing)
- Pretty damn good look-alike.
- Yeah. (laughing)
And I'm just like, "My guy,
I think that's just Sydney."
And he's like, "No, no, no.
Let me show you another picture."
So he shows me a full body
shot of Sydney, (laughing)
and I'm like,
"No, I think you just
got a picture of Sydney."
- I wanna know what Sydney
looks like in this guy's head.
Like the real Sydney, what it
- So, how did he take a picture of Sydney
and like explain it to her?
- No, because what he explained to me was,
"No, you don't understand.
I asked her if she was
Sidsnap, and she said, "No."
- [Joey] What?!
(Garnt laughing)
- Why?
- Because Sydney being
the troll that she is,
sometimes she's like, "Are you Sydney?"
She's like, "No."
(Joey laughing)
So this guy's like,
"Can we take a picture?
I just gotta, you look
so much like Sydney,
I just need to take a picture."
So Sydney takes-
- I can't believe
he was convinced by that.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Just like, "Well, I
guess she's not, then."
- Yeah, he's like, so what
he was saying was he told me,
"Yeah, she looks like Sydney,
and she sounded like Sydney,
but she told me she wasn't Sydney."
- So, this British dude,
so there was an American Sydney look-alike
(Garnt laughing)
in London.
- I think he thought she must
have been cosplaying Sydney.
(Garnt laughing)
- Wait, that's a wig, right?
That's what you really wear.
- He was saying, "It's
your girl?" (laughing)
- I can't believe Sydney
committed to this like at heart.
- I remember 'cause like
I was with a friend...
'Cause we were outside a
hotel, and I was just like,
'cause he refused to believe me (laughing)
that it was like Sydney.
So I'm like, I turned to my friend,
"Can you go get Sydney please?"
He was just like sort
of like shell shocked,
like it was like speech a hundred.
Sydney had like convinced him
that she just was not Sydney
by saying one line that
"I am not Sidsnap."
And then, so my friend gets Sydney,
and the first thing she says
is, "You stupid motherfucker."
(all laughing)
- Joe Baden.
- I love how all it took
for Sydney to get away
from that situation was
her just saying, "No."
Meanwhile, this guy's in
a full fuckin' disguise,
and he can't get away with it at all.
- Maybe I should've just been like,
"No, I'm not-"
- You should've just been
like, "Are you CDawg?"
He's like, "No."
- No, I'm not CDawg.
- Then, it's like, "Oh,
well, fuck, I guess not."
- "Oh, I love your videos."
"Who? What videos?
- "Who? What?"
- "I don't watch-
- "Do you know who we are?"
- YouTube videos."
- You did it again,
what the fuck?
- Well, to be fair, you
weren't CDawg that weekend,
you were CDawgz. (laughs)
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh, yeah. (laughing)
One of my favorite pictures
of the entire weekend
was just your like face of just confusion
in front of your picture.
- It wasn't even like me pulling a...
I was just walking.
- Yeah, he was literally just walking,
and I just like took a candid shot
of Connor just being like, "Ugh,"
in front of a sign that said CDawgzVA.
- It just looked like...
Your face just looked like
you had just gone through,
like you'd seen the end of the universe.
- Do you wanna explain what happened?
Could you explain what this is?
- So at the signing,
we had like a dedicated
section for our signing.
There was a picture of all three of us
that said Trash Taste.
And then there was individual photos
of like The Anime Man, Gigg.
And then, (chuckles) next to that,
there was a picture of Connor,
but it's instead of saying CDawgVA,
it said, CDawgz with a Z, VA.
And I remember, I was admiring
the posters, being like,
"Oh yeah, we look sick in these."
And then I did a double take
with Connor, it was like,
"C, what?" (laughing)
He said, (laughing) "I
don't know what's CDawgzVA."
- Me neither. I liked the name.
- And I was just like, Connor,
you should change your name to CDawgzVA.
It looks so sick."
(Garnt laughing)
- It was that.
And then we'd come in the next day,
and it's just like black tower mark,
and I laughed even harder.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- It was the most like inconspicuous.
Like, yeah, then to pretend
that never happened.
- They fixed it.
- We got this.
They fixed it.
- They fixed it eventually.
- I just kind of felt, I
was like, "I don't care."
Everyone kept carrying out to me like,
"Wow, you must be so offended."
I'm like, "Why would I give a shit?"
- Yeah.
- I mean, I've had that happen before.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
I've had that happen before.
- Yeah, I was just like,
"I don't really care."
It's not like I'm suddenly
now like a different person.
It's not like a file location
where if you type in the wrong thing,
It's like dot C, dot EXE is missing.
It's like, I'm still here.
- At least, the large
majority of your name
was still there and intact.
Like I've been to a convention
where they had a sign up,
and it said, "The Anime Guy."
So I'm just like,
- The Anime Guy.
- "That's just a completely
different person."
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- They must have done that
on purpose to fuck with you.
- No, no, they weren't.
They genuinely thought
I was The Anime Guy.
And I didn't have the heart to tell them
at the time.
- Yeah, just another timeline.
- I was just like, "All
right, you know what?
It's good enough. Fuck it."
- Yeah, for me, like
every convention I go to,
it's like a 50/50 chance of
whether it be Gigguk or GiggUK.
That is like, I swear,
half the conventions I go to
is just GiggUK, unfortunately.
(Garnt chuckles)
- I guess it's our fault
for having confusing names.
- You're in London,
it should've been GiggUK.
- Yeah, it makes sense, right?
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, it's when we go to like Australia,
it'll be GiggAUS, right?
- Yeah, GiggAUS.
- Or just GiggUS.
- In like US.
- GiggUS in America.
But yeah, like another
thing like I noticed
is just like every time you
hang out with your mates
or you were somewhere where
you think you're private,
it's just like if someone mentions that,
wouldn't this be a funny
time for you to get noticed,
it is like the worst fuckin',
it's like summoning the
devil, it is going to happen.
¡Cause that happened to me.
Well, it happened to me indirectly, right?
Because, so we were outside a hotel,
and we were just chilling out there.
It was pretty late at
night. It was about 1:00 AM.
And we see this guy just
stumble over to like the tree,
and he just starts throwing up.
And we were just like, "Fuck, who is..."
"Is he all right?"
He's obviously not in
the right state of mind.
I dunno where his mates are.
So we go over to him,
and he's obviously had too
many drinks that night.
- Yeah.
- And unfortunately, he didn't
know where his mates were,
which if you're watching this,
guy, if you're watching this,
and you happen to be
a Trash Taste watcher,
get better mates.
- [Joey] Yeah, honestly.
- You don't leave your
mates out like that.
- Exactly.
- That's quite fucked up.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, he was by the tree.
Luckily, some guys, like
a father had found him
and was trying to make
sure that he was okay.
And so we went over and
started to help out as well,
just to make sure that he
was kosher and everything,
making sure that-
- He was all right.
- He was all right, he was gonna get home.
So we managed to contact his
sister, and keep in mind,
this like 1:00 AM, 2:00 AM,
like he's just out here
in the middle of London,
and she was like, I believe,
on the other side of London
or something.
- Oh my God.
- And we were like, "Can you
come pick your brother up?"
And you know, being, being the
gigachad sister that she was,
she's like, "Yeah, yeah,
just tell me where he is.
Just let me get there now,
I'll come bring him home.
So we were with him
for like a good like
half hour to 45 minutes,
making sure he was okay,
making sure he was warm,
making sure he wasn't too passed out.
- That's nice.
- And just,
hopefully being a good Samaritan
while waiting for this mythical sister
to come pick him up.
- Being a good replacement
for the shit mates
that he particularly has.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right, right, right.
And so we're with him for
half an hour to 45 minutes,
and then I go into the toilet quickly,
and then as I come outside,
apparently when I was in the toilets,
this mythical sister comes.
And she's just like,
"Oh, thank you so much for
taking care of my brother.
I'm so sorry. I dunno what's
happened to his mates.
I dunno what's happened to him.
I'll make sure he gets home okay."
And then like the next line,
which is the line I heard
as I was walking out the
door to go outside again was,
"By the way, did you guys
see the Trash Taste boys
in MCM today?
(all laughing)
- What, the sister said this?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, the
sister said this, right.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- My mates told me it was
like sitcom level timing.
She was like so compassionate.
And then she was just
trying to make conversation.
And then, she just mentioned,
"Did you guys manage to
see the Trash Taste boys?"
- And then, what?
You just like slowly back inside, right?
- No, no, and then the
automatic doors open.
And then everyone looks
at me, and she just goes,
"No, no! You?!"
(Joey and Connor laughing)
- But you were on the
phone with her, right?
- No, I wasn't on the phone with here.
It was someone else on the
phone, but they had mentioned
that we had a bunch of guys
taking care of her brother.
I was like the guy who was
just like chatting to him,
trying to make sure,
trying to know what the
fuck happened to him tonight
and make sure he felt
comfortable and that shit.
And she was just like, "You
were taking care of him?!"
You!? You?!" (laughing)
And I was just like, "Are you the sister?
Are you the mythical sister?"
And she's like, "Yes."
And I was like, first I said,
"Thank you so much for being amazing."
I could tell like she was like
trying to hold in her excitement.
And then, she pauses for a second.
She looks at her brother,
dead on the floor.
And she's like,
"I know this is a bad time,
(Joey and Connor laughing)
but is it cool if I ask for a picture?"
(all laughing)
- No, no! It doesn't
even sound real, dude.
- 100% it happened, and I'm just like,
"Look, you were like such a gigachad
for coming all the way
out here, like 1:00 AM.
Luckily, we had other people
to take care of her brother.
(Garnt laughing)
We take a quick picture, she
goes home, and everyone's safe.
Everyone's safe.
- Please tell me the
brother was in the shot.
Like in the background.
(Garnt laughing)
It's like that mean picture of the guy
like leaning towards the
grave and like doing that.
(all laughing)
Except it's like
the brother's just like
dead on the floor, like.
(all laughing)
- That doesn't even sound real.
Like it sounds so like in between his ass.
- It does, it was like so surreal.
- [Joey] That's so funny.
One of the funniest things that
happened to me that weekend.
(Joey laughing)
But yes, it's just like,
sometimes you just have like
really weird coincidences
and weird timings with shit, man.
- That is like the words you
must never utter at a con.
Of like, huh, what if? Hilarious, right?
And then almost every single time,
it's like, "Oh, hi," from a distance.
- Yeah, right.
- Fuck's sake. Where's the canned laugh?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Where's
the live audience? (laughs)
- Oh my God.
- Aside from MCM, though,
how is your guys experience
being back in the UK now?
This is your second time-
- Good, good.
- in the UK.
- Only my second time, yeah.
- I dunno if you had a lot of chance
to explore England outside of-
- No, we've been in...
'Cause the MCM in London
is kind of outta the way,
so we've kind of been just
kind of contained there.
- And like the first time I was around,
I think in like 2017,
2018, whenever it was,
I was mostly in Brighton at Garnt's place.
So I think I was only in London
for maybe like a day or so.
I think this will be
like my first proper time
kind of like getting to check it out.
And I've already seen way more of London
than I ever did last time,
so, yeah it's been, it's been chill.
I mean the weather's been
fantastic this weekend as well,
which is great.
'Cause like everyone was like, "Oh yeah,"
when I tweeted about like,
"Oh yeah, I'm landing in London soon.
Haha, it's gonna be sick."
And everyone was just like,
"Weather's gonna be shit."
"Shit weather,
"Expect the shit weather."
- It's been good.
It's really good.
- Yeah, and I landed, and I was just like-
- Brought the red carpet.
- What the fuck?
This is shit weather, you guys?!
- Literally, I remember the
first day meeting you all.
It was like, you couldn't
ask for like better weather.
It was literally clear skies.
It was clear blue skies.
- Yeah, it was like warm,
like not too hot, like
nice and toasty, bright.
You know, perfect, sunglasses.
Like having a coffee
outside type of weather.
And everyone was like, "Yeah,
shit weather, shit weather."
- I was like, "Oh man, you
guys got it good here."
Apparently though, it was
just like an absolute fluke.
Like everyone was like,
"Damn, this is fucked.
It's actually good weather here. Jesus."
- I think around this time
of year it's okay, though.
- This is a pretty good time
to come to London.
- Because the last time
I was in the UK,
it was like the biggest
heat wave in like 30 years
or whatever it was.
- That's like every year.
It's the biggest heat
wave every fuckin' year.
- We get one week, or in your case,
it was like the one month of just-
- That was really fuckin'
hot that time you came.
- Yeah, like holy shit.
- I remember that time.
- Like the heat wave in the UK,
just we are not built for it.
- And I was just like, "Where's the AC?"
(Garnt chuckling)
"Where's the AC?"
- We don't have any.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- I mean, yeah, it's been good so far.
I haven't really done anything. Oh God.
Dude, I haven't really awkward
interaction at the hotel.
It was really like (gasping)
That was of an awkwardness.
- Which one?
(Connor gasping)
- Well, so we were in the hotel bar
just talking to all our friends.
'Cause it's the Sunday,
it's after the cons end,
and everyone's just chilling.
We're all just hanging out,
saying goodbye to all our friends.
And this person was like
pretty chill at first.
And like they would kind
come up and be like,
"Oh, hi, do you wanna drink or anything?"
And I was like, "Oh no,
it's okay, it's okay."
And I got my friend to
buy me a drink instead.
I didn't that their money.
(all laughing)
And then, they were kinda
like, just kept saying hi,
which is fine.
Like it's chill, 'cause
people do it all the time,
and it's like, whatever.
- Yeah, probably a couple of
drinks deep at that point?
- Yeah, yeah.
If someone's having a bunch of drinks
and enjoying themselves,
they wanna be like,
"Oh my God. Yeah, hi, you're there."
It's like, whatever. I don't mind that.
But I noticed that like
whenever we would like...
If I went outside or like
any of you guys went outside,
they would like kind of like
also then happen to go outside
at the same time
and just listen to whatever
you're talking about.
And then, you know, I'd go
to the toilet, then suddenly,
they were in the toilet as well.
And I was like, "Okay, this is like,"
all right, a little sauce,
but like nothing happened.
So I was like, "All right,
cool, cool, cool. It's chill."
- It's kinda like tailgating
a little bit, right?
- Yeah, it just kinda
like watching, I guess,
which is, obviously, it's like not ideal,
but it's nothing bad.
It's like I'm more like,
"All right, whatever."
But then like you guys went to bed,
and there was only maybe
like six of us left.
We were chilling.
And there was like two couches,
and there's like an empty space
because obviously, you guys
had gone to bed and stuff.
And they came over, and they were like,
"Hey, do you mind if
I like take the seat?"
It was like 1:00 AM, so
it's kind of winding down.
And I was like,
"Yeah, I don't really
think that's appropriate
'cause like no one really knows you.
You don't really know me.
And like, you know, it's
kinda weird and stuff."
And they were like, "Oh, oh, okay.
Well, do you mind if I
just introduce myself
to everyone then?"
- No.
- And I was like (inhales deeply)
"Yeah, no, I don't think
that's like the best.
I appreciate it, but like, no,
it makes this a bit uncomfortable.
- So the doing intention is there,
but they clearly didn't
quite read the room-
- Yeah, I was trying to be as like polite,
but like no as possible.
'Cause like at the end of the day,
like there's still
somebody who, even though,
I guess some people would be like,
"No, you have the promotion
to be like 'fuck off'
at that point."
'Cause people say that, and I'm like,
"I still don't wanna do that."
Like to me, it's like,
"There's still a person."
- I don't wanna be that guy, right?
- They shoot at their
shot, and it didn't work.
And they should've just
given up at that point.
But then, after I said
that again, I was like,
"No, I don't think that's..."
"Come on, man, like no,"
They just kinda like
stood there awkwardly,
just like looking at us. (chuckles)
And then, it was just kinda like,
all my friends were
just looking at me like,
and I was like, "Yeah."
- Like "Yeah, please do something."
- I'm like, "Okay, all right, man, bye."
Wouldn't leave, and then one
of our friends just goes,
(Connor laughing)
What the fuck did he say?
He was like, "Just please leave us alone."
(all laughing)
Like he was begging in
like a pleading way.
It was like, "Please just leave us alone."
- Please!
- Please, just leave us alone.
- I think I know who. I think
I can guess who the guy is.
- It was such a like desperate
way that the person was like,
"Yeah, yeah, sorry,
sorry, sorry." (laughing)
I was just like, "Oh no,"
but that was really funny
the way he said that.
(Garnt laughing)
It was really.
- Please, leave us alone.
(Joey whining)
- Yeah.
I mean, when you hang out at
the bar at the convention,
in the convention hotel,
this shit is gonna happen.
Like if we really wanted
to go somewhere else
and like avoid this shit, we could've.
But like we just wanted the convenience.
We were all staying in
that hotel. It's chill.
So like when people do shit like that,
I know people get like,
"That's fucked up that they did that."
I'm like, "Yeah, it's not ideal."
But I'm also like, you know,
"People get excited,
they shoot their shot.
They didn't do anything.
They asked. They didn't just sit down."
'Cause people have done that before.
People just fuckin' pull and grab.
- Yeah, but we've been good.
- On the panel, for instance.
- See, I'm glad people can now know
that we aren't bullshitting.
- No, like you can...
You have the right, anyone
has the right to be like,
"Hey, can I join you?"
And I have the right to say,
"No, fuck off."
- Yeah, exactly.
- You know what I mean?
Like I'm not gonna get at someone
for trying to shoot their shot.
And if you want to, whatever.
Is it kind of rude and
insensitive to do it? Yeah, it is.
But at the same time-
- But at same time,
like respect my privacy.
- Yeah.
If you did it respectfully,
I'm gonna give you the respect to be like,
explain it nicely and be like,
"That's not appropriate, no."
And if you don't get it,
then (chuckles) maybe one of
my friends won't be so nice.
But I'll still be nice, but I don't know.
- Please just leave alone.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, I dunno.
I just say these stories
'cause it's on my mind,
wanted to talk about it,
but I know it's gonna happen again.
It's not gonna be the last time.
If you ever see me around,
and you ask to sit next to me,
I'm probably gonna say no 99...
No, fuck it, I am gonna say no 99-
- 100% of the time.
- I'm gonna say no probably
'cause I don't know you,
and it's weird.
- Yeah, it's like-
- It's not organic.
- Yeah, yeah.
I think in a convention setting,
it's hard to like draw like
a comfortable line, you know?
Whereas maybe if you
meet someone at a bar,
and you're not with like
a massive group of friends
or whatever-
- It's different.
- it's different.
- [Joey] Yeah, definitely different.
- It's very different.
It's you kind of do have to
like read the room sometimes,
which I know some people
aren't as in tune with that
as other people.
But you try not to hold
things against people
unless they like seriously do
cross like a social boundary,
in which case,
maybe I should listen
to fuckin' Ditus more
and just be like, "Sorry man."
- Did you use the man technique?
- Yeah, did you use the man-
- I dunno, I think I just waffled on
for 10 minutes
(Garnt laughing)
Just being like, "No, no.
Here's another reason why no.
Here's another reason why."
- If he would've just said, "Sorry, man,"
then they would be like, "All
right, man, I respect that."
- "I respect," that's
what we should've said
to that guy who came on stage.
Fuck, he was right all along!
- I should've just turned
and being like, "Sorry man."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- "Sorry, man, this just
aint' the place, man."
- [Joey] Oh, man.
- There was this one dude,
and I like (chuckles) still
don't know what his deal was.
I was like, we were at the bar with John,
and John was talking
to me, and I was like,
"John, man, yeah, it sucks, dude."
I was like, "Yeah, it kind sucks."
- Super Eyepatch.
- Sorry, sorry.
(Garnt laughing)
I did it, I did it.
- You literally just did it!
- I did it, I did it.
- What did you tell Garnt before?
- But we've said John like
a million times, right?
I should've said Kevin too.
- It's just there's
so many other John's.
(Joey laughing)
- Literally, such a common name.
- I was in my own head, I'm sorry.
Okay, that's my bad. I suck, dude.
Yeah, I was telling Super Eyepatch Wolf,
I was like, "Yeah, man, it sucks, dude.
I don't feel like I can't
really like experience
a con the way I used to."
And then while (chuckles) I'm
telling this story to John,
this guy who must have
been like 40 or 50ish
just shouts full on from across the bar.
He's like, "Hey, Connor,
Connor, you want a drink?
You want a drink?"
And I'm like, "Nah, I'm good man."
And John was like, "You know that guy?"
I'm like, "No fuckin' clue."
(all laughing)
I know, it's just like so weird.
- I get it because that
happened to me a few times
in other conventions.
- He was nice enough.
He just asked me, and I was like, "No."
And that was it. That was it.
- Because they shout your
name in such familiarity
that even I have to
double take to be like,
"Do I know this guy?"
- Yeah, yeah. (laughing)
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah. (laughing)
Do you know what I mean? (laughing)
'Cause like a few times
when I hang out with mates,
like I will hear like,
"Garnt, hey, Garnt."
And I'm just like, "Oh it's...
Wait, I've never met this
man in my life." (laughs)
- Yeah. (laughing)
- It's like friend of a friend? No?
Oh my God.
- Don't offer me a drink.
"I'm privileged," as you
all say, so don't fuckin'...
I don't need it. I'm good.
- He can buy his own drink.
- I buy my own y'all, I promise.
I appreciate it, though.
Some people are just nice.
I had one time I was
in London last time...
I never told this.
It was like someone in
like a Mexican restaurant.
It was like the thing in the movie.
It was like,
"That person over there
wants to buy you a drink,"
when the waiter came over, I was like,
"This is fuckin' cool.
Yeah, I'll have it."
(all laughing)
He bought me like the strongest
drink on the fuckin' menu.
And I was like (coughing)
- It's like trying to spike you.
- So then I realized, I was like,
"Yeah, I'm not doing this again.
I'm not letting them choose the drink."
- The weirder one for me is like the ones
where it's like just in passing,
but you're also like not too sure either
because the lack of information.
Like it's the ones where you're like,
where you're in the hotel lobby,
and you're trying to get
to the toilet or something.
And then a person is walking past you,
and you just very
briefly have eye contact,
and they just go.
(Garnt laughing)
And then they walk off, and
I'm just like, "Do I know you?"
(all laughing)
- This is something like
"The Number 23" shit.
It's just like, "Wake up."
It's like, "Wake up." (chuckles)
- That does happen a lot.
- It does happen a lot.
And I'm just like...
And it's not until I turn around,
and sometimes, they'll
turn around and be like,
"Hey, love you stuff,"
or like, "Hope you're
having a good night,"
and stuff like that."
You know, maybe they're just
being friendly. I don't know.
But it's like, it's just the silent nod.
Like, what? Is this code
for something? (chuckles)
Yeah, but it's cool, though.
(Connor burps)
- Sorry.
- It's cool.
Like, that's the one
thing, I guess, as well,
that I've just been like kind
of getting back used to again,
because it's like, I personally
have been stuck in Japan
for the past three years now,
and it's like stranger friendliness
is not as big of a thing
as it is, say, in like the UK, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- Especially in a con
setting, so it's like,
I'm just getting used
to just random people
just being like, "Hey."
- Yeah, we've gone from like-
- It's strange.
- I feel like it has been
like just us readjusting
and reacclimating to con culture
'cause it's been like such a...
We've gone from like zero to like 200%
(Joey laughing)
in like the span of a day.
And it just like, I'd forgotten, one,
how intense it was before,
like before COVID and everything.
And now, it's like even
more intense 'cause, one,
COVID'S happened,
everyone's even more
excited and enthusiastic.
And also, we are way more recognizable.
So it's just kind of like all culminated
into this massive stirring pot.
- I know like for me it was...
I caught myself being like,
"Oh man, it's been such a long time
since I've been to a con,"
because there's so many
times during the signing,
where like, 'cause you're
meeting so many people,
you start to get into like
a pattern of things to say.
It's like, you start off with the hello.
Like, "How's your con experience been?
How's your day been?" whatever.
And then (chuckles)
there was so many times
where like people would be like,
"I hope you enjoy your time in the UK."
And I'd be like, "Yeah, you too."
(Garnt laughing)
As if they're not from here. (chuckles)
- Well, there was a lot of people actually
who are like not from the UK.
- Yeah, but it's like clearly,
every time I said "you
too" to that question,
it was always the most like
British sounding person ever.
I was like, yeah, as if
they don't live here.
It's like, "Ah, damn it."
- I think I said that a
few times, not to that,
but like, "Oh, thanks a
lot for your content,"
I go, "You too."
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- It's like, "How did you know?"
- Okay, it's not a con experience.
We had a cab back, me and
Joey and a few other friends.
And it was like 41 pounds, this cab ride.
This, this cab ride.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And you know, I went to go pay.
I gave the guy, 'cause
I only had like 10s,
so I gave the guy 50, right?
So, in my head, I'm like,
"Okay, it's been like three years
or like since I've been
like tipping normally."
and I know that sometimes
you tip cab drivers
in London and stuff, and I was like,
"Okay, yeah, yeah, I forgot about this."
'Cause I never took cabs
when I lived here before.
Obviously, it was late,
and we were in like the middle of nowhere.
So, I pay this guy, and then he's like,
"Oh yeah, yeah, yeah,
I'll give you the change.
Just get out the car, and
I'll give you the change."
So I get out the car, and
I'm kind of just tired,
it's like 3:00 AM.
Like, "Bro, I just wanna go to bed."
And so the guy, I was like,
"All right, so can I have my change?"
'Cause the way I tip, I
don't know if you do this,
I want all my change first-
- And then you give some back?
- Then I will be like, "Here's
here's your tip," right?
- Yeah
- Yeah.
- And so (chuckles) I was like,
"Oh, can I have my change?"
And he was like, "What?"
(Garnt laughing)
And he looked at me like.
I asked for change, and
then he just looked at me
like he wanted me to take it back.
Like he wanted me to pretend like I did-
- Say sorry.
- Yeah.
I was like, "Bro, what the fuck?"
I was gonna tip him, and now
he's being weird about it,
and now I wana tip him less.
'Cause I'm like, "Just
gimme my fuckin'..."
I'm like, "Nine pounds is a lot," right?
This is not America. We don't tip 20%.
I was gonna give him like
a five. That was my plan.
And then I was like, "You're
being weird about this, man.
Just gimme my fuckin' money back,
and I'll give you some back."
I was like, "What the fuck, dude?"
- That's not cool.
- And so, I'm like,
"All right, yeah, yeah."
I was like, "Can I have my change?"
And then he like looks at me.
Again, I wanna say it was the most awkward
five to 10 seconds of my life.
I felt like Za Warudo in Jojo.
I could feel the one second, two seconds.
And I feel like he was trying
to figure out if I was drunk,
I was fine, but I felt like
he was trying to see if like,
he was like, (inhales deeply)
"Can I get away with this?"
(all chuckling)
And so he goes into his car,
he like rummages around,
and he comes out, and he
just gives me five pounds.
And I'm like, "Dude,
all right, okay, fine."
- He's probably thinking like,
"Maybe if I just give him some money,
he might just shut up about it.
- I was gonna give you
the five pound notes.
Now you got four pound
because you're being a dick.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like, "Just gimme my money back,
and I'll tip you!"
It's like, "What the fuck?!"
And I was just like,
"What a weird experience."
Meanwhile, the people in the
car were just like vibing.
They know that I'm like
having like this mind battle
with this cab driver.
It's like, "Just tip him."
I was gonna give him money,
and he was making it weird.
I was like, "Why are people like this?"
- Everyone else was in the car
just like kind of chatting,
and I'm just like dead
on the fuckin' backseat,
not knowing that this is happening.
- I was just like, "Bro, okay."
And so he got his four pound tip.
Jokes on you, you'd have
got a five pound tip
if you'd just giving
me all my change, dude.
This is just a weird experience
you don't get in Japan.
(Connor laughing)
They just give you it back immediately,
and you never have to deal with this.
And it was just so weird
just seeing the guy
just not wanna give me my fuckin' change,
and I was just like-
- It's like, "Me no speak English."
(Garnt and Joey chuckling)
- That was weird.
- It's just like, yeah,
talking about like transport
in London, I guess.
Like, I guess like there has been
like a talk of the town since we got here.
Because everyone that I've hung out with
can't stop talking about
this Elizabeth line
that has just fuckin' opened up.
- Yeah, I like heard about it,
and it's like some like fancy new line
that's like recently
opened up or something.
- Yeah, so apparently, it's
this line that's been planned
that was meant to open,
I believe, in like-
- Oh many years ago.
- Yeah, yeah, like 2020, I
believe, that it's opened?
- Nothing in the UK
ever gets done on time.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
And then it got delayed.
- Nothing.
- It got delayed, but
like the hype was real.
I thought like, "I'm coming to London,
I'm coming to a convention,
people would be like,
'Oh, have you started
watching "Spike's Family?"
Are you watching any new anime?'"
No, everyone's like,
"Yo, you've been on the Elizabeth line."
(Joey laughing)
"Have you been
on the Elizabeth line?"
Like I haven't yet.
- I haven't yet.
- I haven't.
And I swear to God,
someone could just like have
given birth the day before,
and I'd be like, "Baby, nah, bruh.
Elizabeth line, that's the real hype, man.
I gotta try
the Elizabeth line."
- Real shit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But from what I heard, it's just like,
"It's a air conditioned
line," and I'm just like,
"Isn't that just every train in Japan?"
(all laughing)
- And heated seats.
- I didn't notice that actually,
it's like the series of questions we got
were very different to
how the list of questions
I would normally get at signing.
'Cause like before Trash
Taste, it was always like,
"What do you think about this anime?
What do you think about this manga? "
And there was like definitely
some amounts of those.
But I think the top three
questions I received
during that entire
weekend, number one was,
"Have you had a Tesco meal deal yet?"
(Garnt laughs)
Number two was, "Have
you been to Greggs yet?"
- Yes!
- And number three was,
"Have you been to Spoons yet?"
(all laughing)
Like nothing to do with anime.
It was all just like, "Have
you had these things?"
- Have you had any of them?
- Well, yeah, you took me to
a Spoons last time I was here,
but apparently, you took me
into like the worst Spoons.
- Yeah, it was the worst
Spoons. It was the worst Spoon.
- But no, I still haven't had
a Tesco meal deal yet.
- Oh, bro,
I really want a Greggs.
- I haven't had a Greggs yet at all.
So I mean, we're here for a little, so.
- I've forgotten how passionate
people are about Greggs.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's very good.
- Greggs is the bakery?
- Yeah, it's the bakery.
- Okay, yeah, yeah.
- It's so more than that, though.
- Yeah, it is.
(Joey laughing)
It's the experience.
- It's so much more than that.
Just a bakery, dude.
- Like I feel like you have
to go there at least once
to get your British passport,
that's the last test.
- Because it's really weird
'cause I didn't realize
how unknown Greggs was
to people outside of England.
Because a lot of people British people,
we speak about Nando's,
we speak about Spoons,
but like not a lot of people
speak about Greggs abroad,
and it's just one of these British things
that if you're in England,
you would've been to a Greggs
at least once in your life.
You might not always talk about it,
but it's part of being British.
And I didn't realize this
until I came back to England,
and everyone started asking me
if I'd gone back to Greggs yet. (chuckles)
- It's important. Greggs
is an important thing.
I feel from what I heard from people,
like I feel being British
person and not going to Greggs
is like being a Japanese person
and not going to FamilyMart.
It's like that level of
like, how have you not-
- To me, it's even more than FamilyMart.
'cause you can find
FamilyMart all over Asia.
It's like all over Asia.
- I didn't know that.
- Yeah, yeah,
there's like FamilyMarts
in Thailand, actually.
- Oh, I didn't know that.
- It's like 7 Elevens.
- I didn't know that either.
- This is news to me.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
So it's not like a specific...
It's obviously very Japanese,
so like I'm gonna assume
it started in Japan,
but it's like expanded,
but like I believe Greggs
is only available in the UK.
And it's nothing-
- So there's like a really British pride.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So, it's cheap,
and it tastes amazing.
Yeah, what's not to like?
- Best sausage rolls, man.
- Why haven't you guys taken
me there yet? I wanna go.
- I actually haven't seen any.
- It's like the hype
is so real in my head.
I'm like, not only have
you guys like hyped it up,
but like every second British
person I met this weekend
is like, "Greggs, though,
bro, Greggs."
- Let me see
where the nearest Greggs is.
- Yeah, real shit.
- Let me have a look at that real shit.
Yeah, get your boys some Greggs.
And then there were people being like,
"Yo, so like have you been a Tescos yet?"
Have you had the Tesco meal deal?"
And I was like, "Not yet."
And I knew it was like real shit
because like people will like,
"All right, here's my recommendation.
These are the ones to avoid.
These are the ones that
you should go for."
And I didn't realize there were
so many different meal deals.
And like there were people
like in the signing, right?
There would be like a person
in front of me being like,
"All right, so here's the
meal deal I recommend."
And I knew it was a real shit
when like the person behind
them would like interject
and be like, "No, no, no, no.
(all laugh)
Don't spread misinformation like that.
This is the real shit."
And I was just like, "Guys, chill out."
- There's a Greg's 10
minutes away from him.
- Fuck ya, let's go.
(Connor laughing)
- Let's walk off to London.
- After this episode.
- After, after.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But yeah, I mean like we
talk about Tesco meal deals,
but a meal deal is like a lot of choice.
So you need to like
have the optimal order.
- Yeah, I mean, there's just like...
It's like Blackjack, there's
the perfect way to play it.
That's what a meal deal is, right?
So you need to need to learn
how to count cards, okay?
Pick the right meal deal.
'Cause you know, there's
certain items in the meal deal
that you can get where if you
were to buy them individually,
it would cost like two pound 50.
So you can kind of min
max the price options.
So don't be buying water.
Don't get like a fuckin'
little fruit thing,
maximize your cost performance.
- Yeah, you don't wanna
go for Walker's crisps.
- McCoy's crisp, the big boys as well.
- Or the (indistinct)
- Or Walker's MAX.
- Walker's MAX.
- You can't just go
to like the little fuckin'
basic gas vanilla water.
- You can get like an
Innocent Smoothie as well.
There only like two pounds thirty.
- You literally sound like
every person at the signing.
- It's important. It's important.
- I knew it was real as well
because there was like
a bunch of people also,
like when they mentioned
the Tesco meal deal,
they came up to me and they were like,
"Yeah, Tesco meal deals are amazing,
but they opted it by 50 P, and
it's an absolute travesty."
And I'm just like,
"I wish I could feel your anger right now
'cause it seems very real."
- There's one like a one-minute
walk, not even one minute,
like it's literally opposite our hotel.
- Oh, fuck yeah!
- There was this article in the UK
that some doctor was calling
for meal deals to be banned
because they're too unhealthy.
- Really?
- And they're too like appealing.
- Yeah. (laughs) Appealing.
- Because people just buy
these like every day for lunch
'cause it's such good value for money,
and they taste fuckin' amazing,
but they're really bad for you.
'Cause the sandwiches are
like absolutely just stuffed
with awful stuff.
But it's like a McDonald's burger,
it's like, you don't wanna
know what goes in, but you know
it tastes so amazing.
- But it tastes good, yeah.
- Why does it taste so damn good?
What does Ronald put in those-
- FamilyMart sandwiches
are exactly the same as well, right?
- Oh, yeah, you know the
sandwiches are not fresh at all,
but like, yeah.
- But they still taste good.
- They taste really fuckin' good.
- Yeah, I guess, it's like going back to
like why people are
recommending you what to order.
It's kinda like going to a
Chinese restaurant from here
and ordering like compow
chicken or something.
And it's like, "I've had Chinese food."
(Joey laughing)
And then everyone would be like,
"No, you have not had Chinese food."
You know what I mean?
- It's like going on Pan Express.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like, "Yeah, I love Chinese food."
- I'm not even the meal deal guy,
but if you're gonna try one out, Joey,
at least try like the optimal meal deal.
(Joey laughing)
- We'll get the real experience.
- And then we can argue about it.
- [Joey] Fair.
- Some of the sandwiches
come with an additional slice
just for free.
Like just outta the generosity.
- That's not like a
secret menu or anything.
- No, no, no, no.
(Garnt laughs)
- You don't have to say like a code word?
- Normally, it's like two slices,
but some of them for some reason,
they have like one
sandwich and a half in it,
and no one knows why.
It's one of the great
mysteries of the world.
- It's like they're just
trying to figure it out
if you've like truly optimized it.
Like if you're a real player, you'll know.
You see the (indistinct)
- That's how you've gone
through like everything
in the menu, you know?
So you know the good shit.
- I've had a pot noodle yet.
Fuck, I wanna have a Bombay bad boy.
- Is that like the cup noodle...
- Yeah, that's like a cup noodle here.
- Dude, the spicy one is
so good. It's so good.
- Well, I wanna experience this.
- All right, all right, all right.
- I guess if someone-
- I'm just scared that you
might not like this stuff,
and I'll be like,
"This is literally my entire
existence is waiting on this."
Like if don't you don't
like this, I'm gonna die.
- I mean, look, there's a lot of food
that is considered awful
that I absolutely enjoy.
So, I mean, how bad...
Famous last words? How bad could it be?
- You gotta be honest, Joey.
You've gotta be honest.
We wouldn't be the Trash Taste
podcast if we weren't honest.
- I keep forgetting how
shit mayo is as well.
- Huh?
- I keep forgetting how bad mayo is.
- Yeah, I've gone back to not eating mayo.
I had one sandwich
'cause like Japan has
conditioned me to being like,
"Mayo taste good."
I always want the for my entire life.
I come back to England
and have one sandwich,
and I'm just like,
"I don't it, I don't like mayo again."
- Yeah, I always forget.
I just assume everywhere
has Kewpie mayonnaise.
I'm just like, "Oh no,
that was like a delicacy."
- Should've bought your own.
- That's like some real shit.
- Yeah, yeah.
I've kind of like come to this realization
'cause it's a small tangent,
but before the boys came here,
I did go on like a quick trip to Belgium,
and I ate a lot of bread.
- Oh, oh, oh, oh.
- I ate a lot of-
- I'm awake now.
- Basically every meal,
I'd ordered the meal,
and I'd get a loaf of bread.
- Of course.
- And it wasn't like the same loaf-
- A loaf? (chuckles) Like a little bun?
- No, I'm not talking about-
- It was a loaf?
- They basically gave me half a loaf.
- Oh, wow!
- I swear God,
- Damn.
- every fuckin' meal.
Like even if it wasn't a meal,
even if I ordered a drink
with like some quick snacks.
They just give you bread plentiful.
- Belgium knows what's up, dude.
- [Garnt and Joey] Yeah.
- Do you like bread?
- I think I like bread.
(hands clapping)
- That's character
development right there.
- Wow, good.
- I wanna do a proper
like bread tasting stream or something
where I actually try proper bread.
'Cause I kind of realized
that maybe my entire life,
I didn't have shit taste.
Maybe my entire life, I
just grew up in a place
that just had shit food. (laughing)
- You just had shit bread.
- Shit bread, you know? (laughing)
- You can get good bread in the UK.
You just didn't seek it out.
- You just need to like seek
it out, where it's just like,
you'd have to go to like specialty places.
- It's so good, though. Fuck, man.
- Which is like true for a
lot of cuisine in the UK,
which is like, you kind
of get good stuff here,
you just have to seek it out.
- Wait, so what's your favorite bread now?
Like your favorite kind?
- I don't know.
I just tried a lot of bread,
and they all tasted amazing.
I need to get more informed in bread, man.
I'm just like, I just got
given bread, I'm like,
"They have the same bread."
- I want bread.
- My man's finally getting
that bread. (laughs)
- I love it when they give you bread,
and they give you like a
little fuckin' olive oil
kind of dip thing
with like spices.
- Yeah, like the balsamic.
- Oh, I love that!
- And you're like,
"Oh, don't mind if I do."
Like, "Ooh, ooh."
- Oh, yeah.
- Fuck, I love bread so much.
- Every time I go to like
an Italian restaurant
in the states,
- Oh my God.
- and they give you like
that bread with the olive oil
and the balsamic, I'm
like, "Fuck the pasta.
Just gimme more of this shit."
It's so good.
(all laughing)
(phone chiming)
- Oh, I guess I just
got a text from Garnt.
(mobile chimes)
Wait, Garnt just found a new Waifu.
(touch pad clicking)
(mobile chiming)
(gentle music)
(Cartoon character
speaking foreign language)
(gun firing)
(Cartoon Character laughing)
(cartoon character
speaking foreign language)
(glass shattering)
(gun firing)
- Okay.
Oh my God.
I'm gonna have to check this
game out now. Oh my God"
This video is sponsored by
Data A Live Spirit Pledged HD,
so make sure you smash the link
in the description down below
to get a chance to play this awesome game.
Get a chance to have a
fight with your new waifu,
and maybe have a romantic date with her.
So go and press that link in
the description down below.
And yes, that was a
sponsored group chat section,
fellow generates.
I think spending money in
England is way too easy.
(Garnt sighs)
- Yeah.
- Just tapping that card.
- It's like monopoly money.
- So like I know the US has contactless.
Japan has contactless, but like-
- In the form of Suica.
- You can't use at like
restaurants and stuff, right?
It's like for like other places,
and cab rides.
- It is getting better,
though too.
- [Connor And Garnt] Yeah.
- Because I did notice
that a lot of places...
'Cause like in Australia as well now,
it's like, everything is
just like, tablets, right?
- I mean, like in the UK now,
it just seems to be that
like the default is now
the tapping the credit card.
And it's way too easy
to spend a lot of money.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Just something pops up, you're like,
"I don't even know how much it is,"
fuckin' tap and then you're
like, "I'm broke now, shit!"
- 'Cause like I remember
like the first time
they bring that out,
and they just kind like
hand it to you to like tap,
because I'm so used to doing it in Japan,
so I pulled my phone out
to get my Suica ready,
and I was just like,
"Nope, that's not it."
It's credit card. It's credit card.
- Think you could do
with your phone, though,
if you had the right thing set up.
- Yeah, right.
And 'cause I'm so used to like,
even in Japan when you do
like the whole tapping thing,
not only can you see how
much money you've spent,
but it's also like there's
a little bit of a process,
so like, you know, kind of get it going.
But in the UK, it's literally
just boop, and you're done.
- Yeah, yeah, 'cause a lot of the times,
'cause we've contactless here,
they have like a specific
device for contactless,
or they'll like show you the
side with the contactless on.
And it's not the side with the price on,
so you don't even know
how much you're spending
all the time.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
- And like I realized after
coming back this time,
they've increased the limit again.
So when first contactless
started coming out,
I believe the limit-
- 30.
- was like 20.
- Oh, it was at 20? Oh, shit.
- And then it increased to
30, and then, I believe, 40,
and now it's like 80.
We just fuckin' doubled the amount.
- Jesus Christ!
- With a single tap
of your card, you can spend
a hundred bucks. (chuckles)
- That's so scary.
- Like I realized how dangerous this was
'cause we're at the convention,
I was like buying a round
of drinks, and I didn't...
Normally in Japan, they at
least like tell you the price.
They tell you the price of
how much you're spending,
and here they don't
even tell you the price.
They just assume you know the price,
and they give you the contact
thing, and you beep it.
And so I bring back the drinks,
and I remember one of my friends asked me,
"oh, are the drinks expensive here?"
And I would just go-
- Yeah, I didn't know.
- "Maybe." (laughs)
- So I feel like, yes is the
answer, but I don't know.
- Yeah, and I say, "I think
it's probably expensive,"
and they were like, "No,
is it London expensive?
Or is it London hotel expensive?"
And I was just like, "Yes."
- Either one of those two.
- Yeah.
I probably have to ask
how much drinks are,
but right now I literally have no idea.
I just tapped my wallet away.
- I literally dunno how much I've spent
while I've been here, because
again, they don't tell you.
It's so easy.
It's literally just like
throwing monopoly money out.
- [Connor] True. True.
- And being like, "Yeah, cool.
That was easy. Sweet."
And then it's only when
you get back to the hotel,
and you're like, "Oh, fuck."
- I wish it was monopoly money
'cause at least with monopoly money,
you kind of like know
how much you're spending.
You'll know if you're broke.
- I keep track
of my monopoly money.
- Yeah.
I spend it very carefully.
- [Joey] Yeah, that's scary.
- I remember like...
'Cause we had a night,
and we ended up just like quickly,
just like as a group mates in the casino.
And so, we didn't play that much,
but I played a little bit,
and I ended up with some
physical money on me
at the end of the night.
And I remember like cashing out,
getting this physical money in my wallet.
And I was just like, this is useless.
When am I ever going to spend this?
When am I ever going to
spend this physical money
that they've given me?
And because you don't ever
need to spend like cash at all.
- Yeah. I noticed that.
- So now it's just like a
paperweight in my fuckin' wallet.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Suffering from success.
- It's not even. It's like-
- What am I gonna do with all this money?!
- This is just suffering from convenience.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
It is suffering from convenience
that we've gotten to now.
- [Joey] My God, yeah.
- But yeah, I guess that's
been our return to the UK.
- Yeah.
- It's been great.
It's been great so far.
- It's been absolutely amazing.
- Thank you for carrying this episode.
I've been like dead for some reason.
I think jet lags still kicking my ass.
- Yeah, it is a bit.
- I'm like, "Yes, bro."
- It's also really warm in this studio.
- Yeah, it's so hot. I feel
like when I'm in a sauna.
- Yeah, it's like a little extra warm.
- Yeah, at least in like Japan,
we have an air conditioner.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, in my head, I was like,
"Can we turn the air con on?"
And I was looking around briefly.
I was like, "Where is it?
Where is it help? Help!"
But hey, look at all these patreons. Ooh!
- Yeah, look at all these lovely patreons.
I forgot that we needed to shout them out.
- But it doesn't even
feel like Trash Taste.
- No, I know.
- It feels weird.
- Honestly, like I was so excited
to have like the boys come over
'cause we haven't recorded the Trash Taste
in like, I feel, like a
month, three weeks, I think.
- Yeah, almost a month, I think.
- Not, not only that,
but normally at least like
I'm in Japan or something.
You know, I had come to the UK early
to finalize my wedding stuff,
so I was just like here,
and I was just like not
talking to the boys,
not recording Trash Taste.
And I was just like, when
I saw them come to England,
it was just, I dunno, it just felt nice.
It feels nice to have the boys back, man.
- Hell, yeah.
Glad we reunited.
- It feels so good.
- Let's go.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's good to be back.
- Yeah.
- I like it.
- Hell, yeah. But hopefully,
you enjoy this episode.
Hey, if you wanna support the show,
then go over to our patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also, follow us on Twitter,
send us some memes on the subreddit,
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
And we're gonna be here for
next couple of episodes.
- Two more episodes.
- Maybe two more episodes.
- Yeah, about two more episodes.
And then we're gonna be in a
completely different location.
Who knows where we'll be next,
but yeah, hopefully you guys enjoyed,
and we'll see you the next one, all right?
- [All] Bye.
(gentle music)